hello everybody hello hello i wasn't planning on streaming
today but i decided to play a couple of games of rivals
during my little break of doing some work behind the scenes
i'm sorry manager um i'm sorry to my manager if he is
watching i don't know um because i was supposed to record a
couple of things and then i got mad i got mad because um i
forgot today's Saturday.
And because on Saturday, all the lowlifes, not all of them,
but a lot of like low life players emerge during the weekend
queues.
And these type of players are a very special breed of
gamers.
And, um, and they like to do really crazy things during
queues.
Yes, I'm very toxic right now because i was very mad i've
never been this mad before in rivals because i felt like all
right this is how i feel like um yes i am unhinged today but
i'm also on twitch so it's fine um so basically um the game
the first the first two games were pretty like i won't say i
just played i think like three games um i think the first
game and the third game was pretty bad um But then I was
just like, oh, first game, I was just like, oh, Entina, it
was my first game.
I didn't, I never warm up.
I just go in.
And the third, the, their third game, it was pretty bad.
At first, like, you know, like, it was just, it was just, it
was just gaming.
And then the DPS started fucking flaming me and the other
support.
And then even though I fucking saw one of DPS flanking from
goddamn Nania while we were all dying um anyway and then
wasn't it funny the other deep support was a duo with the
other dps player and whoever they were was chatband oh i
wonder why they were chatband i've been playing this game
for since launch never been chatband why the fuck were you
chatband anyway so his duo was talking for him and then the
other support shifted the blame onto me and then was like i
don't know about dokeybird though and then i was like the
fuck why are you shifting the blame on me and then like i
thought we end this together support for life you know like
i was like bro what the fuck we I thought we in this
together also to that one guy I saw you're trying to make a
career out of your out of rivals you ain't making it kid
when you're hard stuck down here and your peak is lower than
mine to the guy who fucking was consistently flaming me I'll
tell you guys I'm not gonna show his Twitter because like
don't like I'm not gonna show his Twitter because like but
he put it out publicly on his rivals thing but i'm gonna
tell you right now you ain't making it kid if your peak is
lower than mine and i'm not and i'm not even playing this
game every day like
i play this game as a fucking hobby and if you are trying to
lft and trying to fucking make it as a pro and your peak is
lower than mine and not even at a hundred eternity by the
way that's sad had so many seasons to get to eternity at
least a hundred since like the by the beginning of the
season easiest shit can't even get it and you're trying to
be pro like bro i'm sorry buddy it ain't the team's fault it
might be you like if you're lower than me and i play this as
a hobby whenever i have time as a variety streamer i'm sorry
buddy Trying to put LFT trialing out for all these teams,
and you're still not in a, you're still not at least tier
two?
I'm sorry, buddy.
It ain't the team.
It ain't your support.
It might be you.
And your fucking poor ass attitude, by the way.
Oh, and your fucking sexism, too, as well.
Forgot to mention your fucking sexism.
I wonder if, you know, maybe change that attitude of yours.
Anyway.
Anyway, continuing the story.
Continuing the story.
Stop, he is already dead.
No, I got it.
Anyway, sorry, I'm on hand-trained.
I've never been, like, this angry before because I was
literally, like, like, they were just hard, like, just
because, like, I think it's because of the Kingsman drama.
So it gave them an excuse to, it gave them an excuse to,
like, because I used my mic because I wanted them to stop
because it was so bad.
It was so fucking bad.
And I used my mic to be like, stop.
Like I solo, I solo queueed here.
Like I'm not dueled with anyone because the guy, the guy
that started the whole like bandwagon on me, like he, like
him got two other guys to nonstop shit talk me in that game.
And I was like, I wish I was live right now.
fucked up and and then they're like oh are you and then when
i tried to defend myself i was like stop i don't think you
know who we were talking to because i was like please look
me up i stream my solo queue stuff um and then they like
they're like uh they made fun of my voice they made fun of
that i was a female player and they're like oh you're just
trying to play the victim right now or are you doing victim
mentality at the moment and i was like bro you guys started
it because the first thing they said to me was whoever
boosted dokeybird to this rank wow i bet i hope that guy is
paying you double i didn't say nothing by the way they said
that second second thing was like um this is all man wow
this is your first time here i'm sorry wow wow i'm so
threatened this is your first time in this elo solo queuing
up here and then i was just like okay and then i went i just
like I am not so I like because I went Mike and was like I'm
not doing it anymore and I'm still right now and then uh and
then and then they're like they were making fun of my voice
they like they started making fun of my voice and then they
were like uh they're like oh you're just I don't because
they they were like oh Kingsman's just going hard right now
because we have a female play and she doesn't know what
they're she's doing and like it was just like it was so much
That's what, like, I hate about this whole situation with
this drama because it gave people, like, they ignore the
bigger picture of what the drama really is.
And, like, and they use it as an excuse to make fun of other
female players.
And it didn't help that I was actually, the enemy team was
Kingsman.
And they used that excuse to rag on other female players
because it has happened in other games as well.
it makes them feel justified in blaming female players even
though i didn't say anything at first i was trying to ignore
them and then the other support player targeted like threw
the target onto me and then three other guys started ganging
up on me and then when i used my mic they were just laughing
at me and then i straight up was like just look me up like
because they were saying even though I literally streamed
all the climb here in the last for this season and
everything too and um and then they were like uh and like
literally like playing playing it all by like on this season
on solo queue like without dueling with anyone um almost
being like on top at top 500 and then and then they were
like wow you think you're somewhat and then in my head it
was like they don't know like and I checked I was like oh
all these people that you idolize they follow me I was like
I when I'm mad I like looked in I was like all those players
all those pros that you fucking idolize, they follow me.
Yeah, and I honestly, I feel like it was just, it was so
bad.
I feel like the rivals, the rivals rank community is so bad
now.
It's actually, it makes me so sad.
It makes me so fucking sad that it's just so toxic now.
like the same um the same level almost the same level as
valorant anyway let me show you guys fuck this guy fuck this
guy fuck that guy and also fuck him cat women stayed quiet
throughout it you cool in my book like especially fuck this
guy like
look them up just if we see them we see them and w cat woman
your movies your first movie with how i don't even know his
first with how bear it might have been pretty bad i actually
enjoy that movie by the way uh fuck you i thought we cool
together i thought me and you we are support we cool
together but apparently we not so i guess fuck you man
supports were supposed to stick we're gonna blame someone we
try to blame the dps or k we don't throw each other under
the fucking bus like you might be chappan for a fucking
reason like
um anyway anyway i just wanted to um i just wanted to let
that out because i needed to let the steam out um whenever
like you know that's like i always say when i get flamed i'm
like i'm gonna stream it because like i always say if i'm
getting flamed and rage baited i'm not doing that for free
i'm not getting flamed roasted or rage baited for fucking
free i might as well monetize that like i play rivals as a
hobby but if you fucking flame me i'm gonna turn on my
stream because at least at least like my chat has my back at
least yeah yeah bro you can cross that's the golden rule
it's the golden rule don't throw your support partner under
the bus bro also fucking crazy by the way the two the and
all the support was duode and then i think the dps was
awesome i don't know the support player was duode with the
dps player yet somehow they were make yet somehow they need
a duo to get to this rank yet somehow i solo queued on
stream not even paying like attention fully because i have
the balance talking to chat while playing the game yet you
need to duo to be here and yet you're you're talking about
how like who boosted you and dueled with you to get to this
elo and i'm like look in the fucking mirror bro you're doing
that right now like yeah like wow
actual bozos anyway let's queue up rank and beat up children
i gotta let out this anger on
game all right all right time to continue the cycle time to
continue the cycle all right here we go all right let that
out i mean if you feel so confident doing that behind the
screen and yet also trying to make it and have a very public
uh social meaning like of trying to have a public presence
and trying to make it as pro in this game maybe think before
you fucking maybe think before you fucking shit talk people
and remember who you're shit talking to think about your
actions uh oh yeah i gotta change my thing i gotta make it
full screen you want to be a public persona if you want to
be a public persona you gotta be very careful with what you
say publicly because it all comes back eventually it's why
it's why i have no opinion on anything except for i guess a
lot of things but they're more not but i would never if i
know someone is a public figure I won't say anything.
Your online paper trail will always come back.
I said in game.
That's different.
All right.
All right, children.
Let's go.
Where are they?
Ah, Mr. Rocket.
Let's do it.
God damn it.
Everybody's closing pub doors now.
Those who have public profiles.
It's like they figured it out.
No!
They know about my reputation now.
They know I frequent here whenever I'm mad.
Whenever I'm mad, I come here.
They heard about the local bully at the playground.
Yeah.
They really did.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm currently matchmaking?
What do you mean?
I'm trying to do it.
Wait, can I not do it when I'm matchmaking anymore?
Has that always been a thing?
Oh.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Oh, what's the point?
What's the point?
What?
Alright, wait, let's cancel queue.
This guy, this guy found the perfect target.
Let's get out of this queue real quick.
Here we go.
No, I found...
I need a warm-up, guys.
I need a warm-up.
No, wait.
Who are you?
No, sorry.
I send the invites.
Not you.
I sent the invites.
Oh, was it this guy?
Wait, where is he?
Did he send that invite?
I gotta warm up, guys.
This is a warm up.
I gotta warm up.
Gotta find the perfect victim.
This is not the way.
The cycle will always continue.
But yeah, that's what...
That's the only...
Like, that's the only thing I really hate about the outcome
of that drama.
It lets people use this as an excuse.
Like, it could be, like, a very tiny minority.
I'm going to try the low-key strat.
It's, like, a tiny minority of people.
But the fact that some people are using that as an excuse.
Oh, no.
That's the worst matchup of...
Time to vanish.
Yeah?
I love Loki.
Um...
You see it?
Yes, so self-re-you see it.
I'm toxic, so I know what toxic people are like.
And...
I'm scared.
Wait.
I never...
Eh.
You're so far from me!
Alright, warm up.
Done.
Warm up.
Let's go!
Yay!
now we cute now i'm satisfied i've let my anger out i've let
my anger look they accepted it it's like is it truly is it
truly bad if like they signed the consent form by clicking
yes to the duel that's that's on them now i'm blaming the
victim like how that guy set out was playing victim yeah
they they had the choice to say no but they consented to
getting their ass beat no no no that was the guy that sent
an invite to me first and then I was like no I picked my own
I picked my targets and then I looked at like that real fast
and I was like oh okay you want you want it your ass beat
okay Okay, that, yeah, sure.
Yeah, he sent the dual invite first.
I said no, because I was at, excuse me, I do it.
I send the invites, not you.
And now, and then I was like, I looked them up, and I was
like, you know what, share.
You wanted to fight me?
Sure, let's do this.
And by the way, I went support, guys.
I didn't pick DPS I picked one of the most broken roles in
this game I picked a role that allows me to have self-heal
compared to any other character but hey hey they said they
said they said supports can't carry And what was that?
I love picking Loki during these duels because it's like,
it's like they have, it's like a little, it's like hide and
seek being like, oh, which one's the real Doki?
Whoa!
I'll never tell.
And it always works.
99% of the time, it somehow always works.
I heard there was a tournament going on right now.
I heard like the J3 community clash, right?
Oh my god, it's, I think it's so funny because like, um,
people who couldn't, who didn't like, uh, who didn't like
make it to the, uh, didn't make it in qualifiers, got like a
second chance in the people, like, because J3 invited like
three captains who basically get in automatically without
having to um without having to like uh go through open
qualifiers so so basically those confirmed teams they just
waited for all the good teams that got knocked out and then
poached those players for the qualified section i was like
that's so smart because there's lots of really good players
that didn't qualify that got like eliminated and they just
waited until because like they basically got like a second
chance because like snake case who was in our j3 team got
picked up by bogey well they got eliminated though they got
knocked out but i was like that's so fucking smart you know
they did they still got eliminated by the way but they got
to have like he got a second life that's a jokie play right
there They literally waited Since they already have like a
spot Like an open spot on Mac Oh my god Gambit's open Okay
Okay I don't need to play Gambit at least I mean I do want
to play Gambit but like I want to chill right I sort of want
to chill I'll play club
Alright let's go
yeah so a couple of players basically got second life for
the for like um for the three captains that got in
automatically how do i get out gm i'm so tired boss what
role are you sometimes it's the role of a dice sometimes
it's rng and it's also sometimes the hours you pick to play
and sometimes do not pick do not play on saturday and sunday
guys also i'll be at the show match tomorrow so you might
get doubles you might get another twitch stream tomorrow as
well and maybe i will actually try and complete the
sponsored portion um but what i'm gonna say uh tomorrow i'll
be at the show match i thought the show match was last week
but it was actually this week bro okay the schedule was like
i was never told what the fucking schedule actually was So
like I got so confused Wait, they haven't okay, I should
play I should actually I should actually play Gambit.
Yeah, I'll play gambit Let me play gambit because we need to
and we need gambit I mean I got I don't want to get fucking
Hawkeye, by the way.
I gotta save my time.
No cards!
Oh my god, this is full of dev.
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, wait.
Oh yeah, no, he was not aiming for me.
That...
He was 100% not aiming for me.
I don't believe it.
Oh, man.
Talk about the cabs, you know?
It sucks because we don't really have a shield.
So I have to, like, have to be very careful.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I'll talk a little bit here, so if we catch some people
being really sexist, I get to clip that.
Wow, that's not cool.
Wow, please, I need kills.
Wait, where did my infest go?
Where is she?
Dude, there's no way we lose this.
I didn't realize both of us were sad.
Like, where did my, where did my Invis go?
It's crazy work, not gonna lie.
I didn't have another dash, which sucks.
I dashed up, and then they still followed me.
I'm gonna use that to heal myself real quick.
Alright, that's fine.
It's no longer fine.
What the?
fuck did you guys see that i i heard nothing i didn't hear
it like okay um i cleansed us i cleansed us wow
oh my god it's dive again why is it always dive i feel like
mechanically we have to have a few players that are just
playing like the worst game of their life for this to be
possible holy fuck i don't know who it is I told you,
weekend queues is fucking crazy.
Nobody, everybody is like, everybody is like so unhinged
right now.
The thing is, this has been like my, all my games today.
Surprisingly.
I don't know, we do have a magic that maybe, I don't know.
We also are other DPS too, to be fair.
We're walking.
Or the Angela back one.
We have like...
We have a magic, but their Hawkeye is so free for some
reason.
Please, I just need you to heal me.
Please just heal me as well!
Oh my god!
Wow.
She wasn't healing me!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh, a TP.
I don't...
Okay, someone else got it.
Oh.
That support is not a bro right now.
That support.
Actually, it's actually gameplay.
Let's go, Dean.
You'll need a top-notch team.
Oh my god.
I was like, okay, I'm getting gonna get healed, right?
Yes
I don't know if she got blinded she got blinded by daredevil
But like every time I ult it I can't be aggressive with the
ult I can't be fucking aggressive with it
Like I literally I'm trying to play with my other support
too
Gambit if you don't play gambit just swap off of them play
your main What the fuck?
I'm...
I...
I ult...
Get dope by two and need a peel.
I can't survive!
What?
We all saw every time I ult, I get dope and then I'm like,
where's my suit?
I'm sitting gamut.
See, I told you.
Like, these games are...
oh my god what do you mean i'm so far oh my god i can't i
can't like like i'm saying like you see that people people
use weekend cues to say like that like and i know it's like
not my positioning there i literally looked at my sue and
nothing happened sleepy minus oh use my movements
All right, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, I am using my movement.
Whoa, I'm using my movement.
Is that what you wanted?
Oh, all right.
Oh, whoa.
Oh.
Use my movement!
I left!
Whoa, what happened there?
Whoa!
All that amazing.
Score, 0, 2, 1.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
Oh, my God!
Player made?
Oh, wow!
Oh, wow.
Have you won tournaments with Gambit?
I have.
Well, the other guy's half, bro.
Yeah.
What a fake, yeah, right?
Is that crazy?
Is that fucking crazy?
The games during the weekend?
People that, this is what I'm saying.
This is what I'm saying.
these times it's like like during this day it's fucking
crazy they're like why just use movement and i'm like oh i
moved out where did they go i moved out again i just get
dove
it's actually crazy i think they avoided me i don't need to
avoid them i don't want waste of boys wow wow and you link
your discord too you're so brave you're so fucking brave
like so it's because it's the usual i mean i don't care
about my elo i literally play this game like i play this
game for the vibes but i try like i still try i'm not like
desperate for
Happens.
Yeah.
Not the vibes.
I hate that they ruin vibes.
I literally just play just because it's rank and it's fun
for me.
But like, I stream whenever at, like, if it's, like, moments
where, like, people are being extremely sexist or toxic,
like, I stream.
Because if I'm going to get beat, if I'm going to get
roasted, like, I'm not going to roast it for free.
I might as well make it content.
word is gone now i always say i like to play for the vibes
because i do have fun competitively and like like i like to
play rank as a like as my off time because i do enjoy it
like i don't care about my rank what my rank is i just like
playing the game like i try like if i get points yay if i
lose points oh no yeah like if i lose points oh well gg go
next but Like, I already got top 500.
I already hit my goal.
Like, I got top 500.
I hit my goal already.
So, like, for me, for me, like, I don't need another top
500.
I'm just playing.
If I get it, that's cool.
If I don't get it, oh, well.
I already have a top 500 badge.
Yeah, and then, like, it's like...
Um, also, that's very brave for the TTVer to fucking talk
shit.
Like, it's very brave of them.
Like,
if you're, I guess if you're like, yeah, unless that's your
whole streamer personality and the fact that they have a TTV
name.
I don't put my entire self-worth on.
I do.
I do when the game first comes out, because I would get
depressed when...
I do when the game first comes out, but not like...
I can't challenge people in ring.
Like, what's the point?
I thought, like, duels...
I feel like duels, you should be able to do it when
you're...
For duels, you should be able to challenge someone when
you're in queue because to pass the time.
because it's like death match.
It's the perfect time, place to pass the time.
Now I guess I'll just go to the club.
I guess I'll just go to the club.
I'll go dance and hang out.
Where are they?
Wait, where's the club?
If someone leaves your match, then they get...
It's annoying.
Yeah, but I'll take it.
Oh my god, no one likes to go to the club no more.
No!
Where did everyone go?
Terrorizing the elop.
Terrorizing rank right now.
Like me.
Just like me.
Dancing is old school.
You gotta keep up with the time.
No!
No one dances no more!
What do I do when no one wants to dance?
This is why Rivals is dying.
There's no more whimsy.
I'll play Cloakless.
I don't know.
But they have a mag.
Rivals is dying because no, there's no more whimsy anymore.
Only...
I think the non, the back-to-back.
rival's drama isn't helping out the whimsy is dying and all
we have left is trauma
no the back to back to back um the j3 apparently there was a
apparently a hacker team allegedly hacker team made it
through are still playing in the tournament um and then a
big google dokey was dropped about this alleged hacker
because apparently um um he's friends and his mods his
friends and his like mods are all hackers so like people
were like well that's pretty sus already if his friends and
his mods hacked in rivals um and he got called out as a
hacker so it's like but then people um but then they're like
we checked his pc so but he had he got chance to restart his
pc before they checked his pc so it's like there's no way to
actually catch him but it's very suspicious and the team
that had the hacking team the team that had the hacking team
knocked out several teams that could have made it to the
finals so it's just very suspicious and like obviously net
ease doesn't want to be like very like 100% yeah he's a
hacker because they're worried that you know what if they
ban an innocent guy They want to be 100% sure if he's
hacking or not.
But the cheats that he could have is very hard to catch.
So, like, you can't 100% confirm if it's a hack.
And since NetEase is a very big company, they don't want to
be like, yeah, he's hacking because then, like, it would,
you know, affect their reputation if they're wrong.
So they only confirm stuff if it's, like, 100%.
Whoops.
Yeah.
So it's like...
I'll drop down.
Well, I'll keep somewhere.
Don't worry.
He was scared.
I'm gonna keep my thing.
Oh my god, I wanted to keep it for it.
Now if we get dope, we're a little fuck.
It's a little fucky-wucky and we get... Oh!
Oh, that's very unlucky.
Holy shit.
Yeah, this sucks.
I was gonna say we get dope.
It's gonna be really bad for us.
Oh, my God.
I want to get out of here.
Let me out of this ride.
Let me out of here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Thank God the mag doesn't have all.
Yeah, I took a gamble.
I took a gamble.
I'll be like, I hope the mag doesn't have all.
That will be very awkward.
Please copy me.
Oh, God.
Good luck, good luck, Loki!
Good luck!
Alright.
Nice.
I took the gambit, exactly.
There we go.
He misses.
I instantly played away.
I was just like, not me.
Even though it should be me.
Not me.
This is not me.
Oh, shit.
Good luck to all of us.
That's good.
Oh, God.
Our kitty can't die.
That's good.
Oh, my God.
That is not...
Oh, wait.
They do have venom.
Oh, no.
Please live.
please live I almost have all please no stand in it no
you're supposed to stand oh my god he was supposed to stand
in your he didn't stand in it why didn't you step goodbye
I'm dead thank God he didn't stand in it he walked out I
could have got my health charge so fast.
Oh, no, low key.
Oh, I go here.
Alright, I still have low key.
Or still venom.
Well, um, I hope my two DPS lives.
Or like, oh, wait, no, it's just Emma.
It's Emma.
Emma will be fine.
I believe in the Emma.
Oh, wait.
Alright, I'm gonna keep my thing when the venom goes high.
I should swap, though.
I should just swap to Invis.
Because I think I think I...
Don't worry!
I got this!
Okay, you didn't need to use that.
That felt like a waste, but that's okay.
I think I'm on it?
Like...
Oh, no.
Oh, where's my Loki?
Oh, why is he so far away?
Loki, why are you there, Loki?
Our team needs you.
Our...
Oh, Loki, our team needs you.
How are you over here, bro?
No.
oh dope please oh dope
i wish we had if only we had a shield if honestly we had why
didn't you die on point loki i we needed you I don't
understand He's He fucking Stalled for so long He has like
No confidence in me Is it?
You know how I know Because he fucking When we get dope He
fucking There we go I have to use that.
Can we move forward?
Can we move forward with this?
This is the most aggressive all I can do for us.
What the?
I live.
Oh my god, they really...
Don't spy.
You can tell that I did not care.
Oh my god.
Get me in here.
Go look over again, okay?
All right, here we go.
Loki, please come back.
Please come back, Loki.
Loki!
Oh my god, he came back.
He came back.
Oh my god.
He actually came back, I'm so happy.
He's crazy.
I don't know, he's fucking wild for that.
I literally thought he was fucking dead.
Where is that?
Ah,
fuck it.
We're gonna go.
Okay.
Oh, that is...
that's good that is not good oh my god i don't think that
hits me oh i'm dead oh i'm dead i try to get out but it
didn't matter that's okay please i'm right here look around
look up look around turn around i'm right behind you you
can't copy me right here please i'm right here it was like
not looking behind me and i got scared i got scared for us
jesus how are they taking so much where's my low key
oh i'm scared
now oh i'm trying i swear to god
okay oh my god this is a stall of the fucking century right
now oh my god not a please
we have another one
oh i don't know but i guys i don't know about that now
it is truly The stall of the century right now.
Please, I am 86.
Oh my god, he missed.
Please, please, please, please, please.
No!
I was literally one.
Oh my god!
He missed.
Holy shit.
That was the stall of the century.
oh my god not me i didn't get blamed i can tell you don't
play dps on your positioning what are these games every game
someone is toxic what the fuck are these games like what why
is every game like this.
That's fucking crazy.
Everyone is so mad.
Why is everyone so mad?
There's...
Literally, 3 out of 3.
Someone is mad at someone.
But at least this time, it's not me.
It's not...
It's not me.
I didn't get blamed this time.
Yeah, oh boy, I can't wait to relax and play Mara Ramos.
He was going to play on the most toxic games ever.
At least it wasn't me.
I am teaching all of you guys to don't play on the weekend.
It's a special breed of players as this day.
I normally don't, but today, because I usually have a
different stream on Saturday, so I'm too tired to play on
Saturday or Sunday.
You know what?
Saturday is my free day.
Let me play some rivals.
And I forgot what it was like back then.
I really did.
I usually never play at this day.
I do it for you guys.
I'm showing you guys.
I'm showing you guys what the experience is like.
all right are we are we even okay bro hopefully holy shit i
don't think so i guys please i can't heal all this damage i
please there's so much damage guys okay look i'm gonna do
something fucking crazy and i need you all to agree on this
with me there you go all right there you go oh my god it
worked the crazy shit worked the crazy shit kingsman what do
he knows me i i don't even i didn't realize today was the
first time ever i've seen ever been bumped into him in ring.
I know we all know you, though.
Today was the first time I've ever bumped into Kingsman in
ring because I'd never play at this day.
Alright, kill our cloak, not me, though.
Oh, fuck, I didn't mean that.
Oh, shit.
That was just a joke.
I didn't think he'd actually do it.
I didn't think he'd actually kill him.
Oh, man.
I guess it sucks to be our Loki right now.
Oh, I should help him.
Hello.
He really went.
Okay, sure.
I mean, yeah, just add me.
It's just Jokey bird.
I don't want to use it.
I kited.
Poor hell up.
Hoping for your Phoenix.
Our poor Hella.
Where is he?
Is he gonna?
Oh, I thought he was gonna do it.
He's just gonna chill.
Okay, I don't think he hit anybody.
Like I literally think he missed.
All right, here we go.
Round two!
It's okay.
He already used the rock on the other on my Glocki.
Yeah.
All right, again!
There we go.
What the fuck?
Did they actually like...
Oh, I should help.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
I saved your life, you're welcome.
I don't think we're winning this, but like, you know, it
looked cool.
He missed.
Alright.
Let's go.
Come on, guys.
At least if we're gonna lose, at least we got gotta make it
look like close you know we gotta we at least look like we
tried we're guys come on believe in all of us
oh shit i don't know how he died okay loki you thought i
thought you needed heals loki come on copy me you know you
want to there we go i need you to bait the the maga Oh,
Mago?
Thank God.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Not me.
Alright.
Free alt for me.
I mean, it's just him.
Nice.
I didn't have to waste it.
Oh.
What?
I thought...
Oh my god.
I thought... You know, I I thought he would not shoot me,
but he did.
It's alright.
It's cool.
Oh, I should have stayed home.
I didn't believe in my team.
He literally shot me in the...
I literally had like 20 bodyguards surrounding me.
And then I still got shot.
Like, that's crazy.
I swear, I was in the center of all that, too.
But I still got shot.
All right, here we go.
Boop, boop, boop.
All right.
Do they need me?
I think they don't need me.
Watch this.
All right.
You thought you're always sick?
That's right, because the mag doesn't have all the ice, so I
have to do this.
That's right.
That's sucking right.
You're a low-key old last shorter.
For those who don't know, if a low-key copy's cloaked, her
all is shorter than uh a regular cloak call because of the
timer it doesn't extend the copy for some fucking reason i
don't know why it's looking weird yeah it it disappears
faster so that's why yeah it's only for cloak i don't know
why oh no don't worry loki i got you copy me i'm right here
please i'm right loki please where are you loki please
before Where he goes?
All right, thanks.
All right, let's blind you.
I got a little scared there.
All right.
She'll be fine, right?
Yeah, she'll be fine.
There we go.
Could be a bug?
Who knows?
It works for me.
Please, please don't let him.
Don't let her do this again!
She's just standing there!
Yay!
I was just like, excuse me, I see a phoenix standing in
front of all three of us.
Yay!
Absolutely winnable.
Yeah, that phoenix wanted to fuck me up.
Yay!
All right, back to Times Square.
sad i'm so sad i can't do it to all the kids all i can do is
dance great thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank
you you guys liars i don't have a friend request
you're liars
i mean
Is it?
Does he actually...
Well, my name is easier.
My name is a word.
I swear on my dogs.
Would you pay on your dogs in the club?
Doki bird is a word.
It's like two words combined into one because I removed the
space.
So it's technically a word.
all right oh wait there it is wait who's mega 993 he's like
i'm kingsman too i assume it's it i assume i was like wait
who's this guy he is all he's kingsman's little brother
viola thank you to your one so thank you thank you flaming
bird thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you all
right request to join oh okay oh i thought i said cat i
requested to join all right i requested kingsman hello oh
hey why does it you like to play some marvel rivals yeah
that's fucking rip it let's get it let's get it are there
other just losing that tournament Uh, wait, what?
The J3 one?
Oh, did you lose that?
Yeah.
Um...
Wait, don't you guys get, like, automatic money, though, for
qualifying?
Yeah, we do.
I have no idea how much we get.
You know what?
Free money, let's go.
Yeah.
That's the best part.
You get...
Even if you lose, you get...
You still get the money.
I read what my viewers were saying in your chat.
I don't think I'm going to send anybody to represent me
anymore.
Oh.
I'm saying he needs it bad.
He needs it bad.
Bro, when you need it bad, I'm lower ranked than you.
I didn't say anything.
That's not what I said.
I'm repeating what they said.
I'm just saying like, bro, this is what you're doing with me
is a lottery.
It's like, my highest rank.
When I actually played this game, I think I got to...
Wait, I need to ask my chat.
I don't keep track.
guys what was my highest rank guys oh i peaked rank 29 in
season one and and then when i ended top 500 yeah like when
the season what i don't remember i remember it was in season
one when i actually gave a and then after i got top 500 i
just chilled i just i just played whenever i free time um
well after that i just play on and off i don't like grind 24
7.
i always just like at the end of season i just get to
eternity during the last week of the season and then log off
okay okay yeah uh you think we're gonna get one of them all
tonight bro it's the weekend bro what the fuck are you
talking about we get queues are the worst queues what are
you talking about it doesn't matter when you queue just
queue no no no i literally had four games in a row and every
game, someone will blame somebody.
It's so bad.
That's just regular competitive experience.
No, no, no, no.
It's the weekend.
Bro, it's the weekend, Qs.
He doesn't know.
Listen, listen, listen.
Marvel rivals might not always be the best experience, but,
through the torture you find glimmers of hope and happiness
and and that's why i play this game yeah are you are you
happy right now i am absolutely jolly
bro i saw yesterday's stream but i won't say it i saw
yesterday's stream went on the trade poker badge i won't say
it Uh, laptop in pitch black Locked in I won't say it He's
good fives right now We can't ruin the good fives We can't
ruin the good fives, guys He's good fives right now I didn't
hear all of it But I saw I saw World War 3 I saw I saw World
War 3.
Well, I'm always locked in.
All right.
Not in this game.
It's okay, he didn't hear that part.
I've been streaming for nine hours, but I'm prepared.
I win.
Whoops.
I only need to win like four more games.
I didn't click on it.
It's one of them all and then I'm done on the scouting.
I'm going to be touching the shit again.
All right.
Here we go.
Alright, I'm here to make it five games, don't worry.
He said four, right?
He said four games, it needs to be one above us.
I mean, what are you...
I'll make it five games.
Yo, can I get a boost here, please?
Pretty peace.
No, I just...
I swapped the squad, yeah.
Yeah, I don't think you...
Just four more games?
You mean just five more games?
And then five more games?
Just six more games.
Six more games?
Just seven more games.
We're ready to go on an adventure.
Okay, guys.
Alright.
See, look.
Oh, goodbye.
this whoa he asked oh my god look at him he's our diver he's
diving the Kingsman experience oh my god I get to experience
I get to get the Kingsman experience right here oh my god
that one guy that roasted me being like who took you up here
oh my god I could fight I could be like um Kingsman did I'm
Yeah That one guy I'm ready if you're right.
That's right.
Oh Shit don't worry.
I got you buddy
What oh shit that rocket is crazy Yeah, that big big big I
killed her I killed her in a second.
Yes There we go Take that one guy bro.
He was like He was like gassing up Kingsman too.
That one guy.
That's right.
Didn't even plan it.
It all just happened.
He was gassing up Kingsman while he was like, he flaming me.
W-5.
That's right.
I'll make sure I'll play with all your idols
unintentionally.
Alright, here we go.
I normally don't talk in game because it's like There we go
That's right we're so healthy Oh my god I'm still so healthy
Oh not you though Not you though Oh my god Yes though though
Oh I missed that I shot I pulled a pull Oh
all right oh my god sorry I brought him closer to us I
thought that was a smart thing to do yeah you want to you
want to rock it usually it is yeah I can all right it's bad
try a big curtain oh oh they have punishers I think it's
fine it's not all right goodbye I'm alive KDA player
unintentionally I got this oh my god need water I gotta wait
until this game Got you That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
We're five.
We're still healthy.
Thank you for the raid.
I'm sorry for the very intense game right down Oh my god,
please please This game is very intense.
I bought I bought three two one big all incoming Look at
their back.
All right.
It's fine.
Okay.
I pulled him.
I pulled him Please, he's so low!
Where is he?
Where did our bird go?
Someone kill him, please.
There we go.
Well, Snuffy, thank you for the red.
I hope you had a good stream, Snuffy!
Oh, no.
Oh, mad.
Get out of here.
Oh, no.
Look at the left.
There's more to the left.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
We're so healthy.
I push him out of that.
I pushed him out of that.
Push him out of it.
Push him out.
Oh, my God.
I have to be the smartest play I've ever done.
Thank God.
Just shoot Mark.
You want your for the vibes.
Oh, well, girl.
There you go.
Please kill this guy.
oh my god why is he still alive
yeah oh good back though and she's yeah but i hope you had a
good stream snuffy
oh my god that's right come back hulk oh i still got you i
got you i got you i need that all charge don't worry don't
die i need you i need you for your ult my little alpha
battery
oh whoops whoops whoops whoops who put that wall there oh
man um we can be here what is he gonna do shoot us fucking
idiot what the is he gonna is that guy gonna do yeah let me
walk and get wiped here all right oh battery come back my
little old battery
it's okay that's all right if anybody's gonna get blamed
it's not gonna be me
okay it's fine um you cannot blame him he's aced right now
guys i'm ready to uh I think we do it.
I think we do it.
I'm ready, rocket.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm living here.
What?
It's partially defensive.
Shoot the ironfish.
Goodbye, goodbye.
I'm trying to...
Oh, old battery.
Oh, this is not good for me.
I'm living here.
I'm prioritizing my life.
Okay, I have a shield here.
I have a shield here.
Oh, it's two of them.
It's fine.
This is...
It's like we don't need to worry about the Punisher.
Don't worry.
Okay, I forgot about the Punisher ult.
But it'll be fine.
What is he gonna do?
Punisher ult right now?
Ooh.
Got it, got it, got it.
Got it, got it.
All right, still a gruel up there over to me.
Kill it, kill it.
Nice.
We're full, full.
Shoot their hole.
That's five.
We got push him.
I pulled him back.
They're down too.
I still covered.
Yeah.
And we have Rocket Alts too.
We'll train them in a second.
Wait, Rocket and we're both gaming.
We haven't died yet.
We win.
We win here.
We're in here.
They're still down too.
Okay.
Oh my god.
The Rocket almost died.
Nice.
Now all of them turned out.
We win.
Yeah, I learned about kiting from over back.
One walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Walking, walking.
Look at their enders.
Wait, fuck what happened to me?
I'll kill everybody here.
Get him out of here.
There we go.
See, everything is fine.
Just trust the process.
You just gotta trust the process, guys.
What is he gonna do?
Punish me?
Guys, I told you.
yeah guan guan blessed us today guan guan blessed us for
this one game
yeah what's he gonna do shoot me so maybe he's just blessing
my cues oh my god he doesn't know i'm the anti i'm the anti
cue he doesn't know he doesn't know this one game he doesn't
know i'm the infamous e-o-m-m terrorist he didn't do his
research you're not
yet he doesn't know i'm i'm the sleeper agent
all right little does he know we like we will be like one
game away from one above all and then and that's when it
happens it's not because of like my me playing it's just oh
my god someone break the wall and save him all right it's
just it's just the curse
i am a little concerned about the spider man just a little
bit concerned he's gonna grab me and i don't want to get
grabbed oh i had to reload oh i don't want to be in here no
more don't put me in here wait is this a bad walk this is a
bad while we're why are we here what are we doing
Well, no
It's okay every bad Groot wall every bad Groot wall.
Yeah, girl.
Yeah, he has like one one good one Uh-oh, they're on Black
Panther.
Oh, no, he's tilted Gotta be careful Oh god.
Oh, I'm here to save you're alive you're alive Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, no, he's not.
I should have let you die.
I should have let him die.
Oh, Maya.
I should have...
I should have not cared about his life.
You're welcome.
I'm gonna be curious.
Oh, they walled it.
Let me just stay here.
You didn't know I was here.
Wait, what the fuck?
Good armor.
Alright, it's fine.
Jeff there, Jeff there.
Okay, we're all okay.
We're still healthy.
See?
Oh, wow.
I know, Rick.
I told you.
Yeah, trust me.
the process like how the hat hella is just standing emoji
right now he really is playing the wildest game of his life
oh my okay i did not time that but if it works it works i'm
ready travels maybe i'm just like get it in there put it in
there put it in there all right this time this is it he's
gonna he's gonna be able to put that all in okay okay yeah
he did it he got one guy Okay, I gotta save it for...
He did it, guys.
He got that one guy.
Oh, oh, yay.
Oh.
Yeah.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Maybe it's his first game.
Small thing.
He's gotta make sure.
Oh my god, did he really slow?
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good.
Oh my god, that guy really...
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, I don't want to...
I'm a little worried about...
I'm gonna save my...
Okay, you're gonna be fine.
Okay, I...
I thought he would throw it.
I thought he would...
I was like, guys, he has broken, he has Punisher on.
I thought you would throw it They still have rock Oh my god
We do have shoe all We do have shoe all Can we sue aggro?
Can we sue aggro?
There you go, there you go Go over, get him, get him, get
him!
Oh no!
Wait, that's the biggest!
That's actually crazy!
Oh, I missed I got res though, I'm back
Okay.
I actually missed the...
I can TP if he's tall.
211.
Don't miss it.
Oh my god.
What?
I should have went around.
I panicked.
I forgot there's another hole.
I might have panicked there.
I could have went across.
I did not expect that.
I could have went around, but like, you know, when you get
kidnapped, you know, you don't really think about there's
another hole.
Like, you know, you don't expect to get abducted.
That is very smart, though.
It's, people usually do that.
It cut off yours.
actually like just cut off he was oh god no
okay we got oh nice that's a good okay that's okay they
can't they can't burn this No matter what, I do need our mag
please.
There is an alt behind you
Oh god Oh, that is huge.
That is huge Oh, he got the ult just in time It's okay Oh my
god Hold nice point All right our rocket hesitates a bit
because it's like Invis, Invis, we're Punisher and then my
rocket looks at me and was like you're gonna save me, right?
And I'm just like, is that a Punisher?
They're fine.
You're so healthy.
I'm on, I'm on.
You're walking.
Save me a big wall.
I'm walled, I'm walled.
Okay.
I'm a dead.
Pulling it back.
Oh my god, he jumped!
Good run, good run.
Okay, when they jump, they give you a bigger pull, which is
the best part.
You gotta pull them when they're jumping.
That's brutal again.
It's like why, like, when people...
Okay, I got...
Here you go.
Street!
No!
Please, Hulk!
There's ours.
Oh, I'm back!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I die on card.
I mean...
Well, they use everything, so...
I'm going to win.
Ironfish.
I always have to watch my mag.
I have to always just watch my mag.
Come along.
on the left i think we should girdle right now i'm ready
yeah i'm girdling on the rest line just rocker rocker oh i
didn't have we just got in this area i'm gonna get the walls
yeah they're down to support walk walk all right nice that's
good shoot fish shoot fish shoot fish oh come on that was a
pull you didn't even block that come on that was obviously a
pull I didn't block Come on Mag please Oh no Mag please Okay
that's good Two rocket on rocket Where's the rock hill?
I'm just gonna use that to keep...
Alright, there you go.
Please, please come into my lap.
Nice.
Oh, no.
What you gonna do?
I have... No, okay.
I don't have a shield no more.
Oh, no, please.
There we go.
Yay!
Yeah, I'm ready to try that.
We did it!
Let's go!
You guys?
All those walls.
Bro, our mag.
Our mag.
I swear to you.
I just watch him.
I'd be like, so long, mag.
Goodbye.
Every time.
Every time I see the mag, I knew it was over.
I knew he was gonna die.
And I can't do said anything about it.
I know.
Thank you for gifting us up to pal.
Thank you I'm gonna grab water I'll be right back bathroom
break I'll be right back He's been says anything Yeah Yippee
Oh Yippee Alright If he says anything Say I'm fucking peeing
I don't know
I'm back for real Sadly I forgot to get water And then I
forgot to Blow my I forgot to get Uh, I forgot to get
Kleenex to blow my nose.
I ran out of paper, tissue paper.
I will say that might have been my best Invis gameplay since
for the season.
I was not focused at all.
I was not like, I was not like unlocked.
in 100 percent locked in there but yes somehow i think i
like tried like i would just hit my flow state kinksman was
in your game last game i hope so i hope the guy i'm dueling
is actually kinksman i hope my duo is that the real kinksman
unless he's not the real guy
no way
plot twist he wasn't actually Kingsman because that
literally is just a it was me Barry
just a random day I got to I got tilted at some random
that's my fucking teammates it became a Stream day.
That's how it goes.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
I play Rocket.
I play Rack Time.
You guys play Heels?
Because I can heal if you want to tank.
I don't know.
I have a Lord Rocket.
Do you guys play heals?
Ask the Lord.
Ask the person who has a Lord on support.
Oh yeah, I forgot to unbandarot word raccoon to celebrate
getting third yesterday.
I forgot about that.
Yeah, in honor of the snuffy raid, I shall play Rocket.
How's it getting guys?
Uh, you guys want to TP on their back line?
Yeah, that's a little goofy Be a little be a little special
All right, here we go Oh shit, we're actually gonna do it.
Give me give me a count All right, here we go
Here we go.
Does he know is he is he oh What the fuck Holy shit.
Okay, that was a good-ass T-kindaf.
That was a really good...
Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
There's still one more guy behind us, by the way.
For those who don't know.
Look, look, one.
See, you got res.
You got res.
Looks one on point.
There's one push.
I can pull down.
No put on's on there.
No, I'll kill.
I'll kill your invis.
I'll kill your eyes.
Okay, um.
Don't worry.
You're in his res and his res.
Keep your rocket alive.
Oh my god.
I got nope he did not
What do you mean got no heels?
I'll fucking see bro that rocket saved two of his dash you
freaking freak must be nice Okay, I don't care how did that
rocket have two dashes?
He's still one that little rat that fucking rat.
I got chased by 20 people Are you fucking kidding me?
Please!
Invis!
Look at me!
Look at- okay!
That's it!
Cat spawn cap now if I'm invisible.
It doesn't even matter.
Doki?
Please tell me when you get dove so I can...
Oh, yeah.
Are you please?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I need to do a little more.
Thanks for the boost.
Alright.
Can't dove me now.
I'm on their backline in three, two, one.
Oh, my God.
You're so fine.
Can't, I can't heal you forever, though.
You gotta, you gotta learn to fend for yourself right now.
Like, that is so awkward.
Okay.
That, that was actually planned.
Oh my god, that was fucking planned.
Holy shit, I was ready to click my snap.
And there's no you have to be duode.
There's no fucking way.
There's no fucking way that guy is not duode with a mag Who
the fuck plans that?
Who plans a goddamn grab?
Okay, who fucking plans that?
I know you don't have this no more So I'm coming for you a
raccoon
this is bad this is so bad that is so bad all right i got
swap off actually i swapped it in this that's so fucked up
no we can't oh my god that's crazy the fact that i got
grabbed you're gonna commit to a dive con with these guys
the fact that got spider-man grabbed into the mad god is
insane i've never had that happen before that was the
craziest shit ever do you play phoenix or i played it more i
don't play phoenix okay yeah yeah who fucking does that
that combo was insane this is looking like he did say he
needs four games to one above all maybe we'll just be stuck
on four games honestly respect that's the most big brain
i've ever seen you don't want me to you here i could go back
here it does not look like an accident he grabbed me the
moment he slammed down i need you to know that your mic's
not working brother no you're my Grab me the moment the mag
did his slam.
Literally, I was ready to press the swap button.
And I, and it like, and then, and then I got the grab.
Alright, move forward.
Oh my god.
I bubble, I bubble.
Jesus Christ.
I can die behind me.
Please, please, please.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, we didn't have another bubble.
She just got that bubble too.
I think it's just a team diff.
We don't have anyone that actually counters the spotty.
Like we don't have a Bucky player, I think.
I don't know.
I think it's just Or maybe a triple supporters up there
Usually you play triple support against Spider-Man Because
then he's like worthless in game
He doesn't see He doesn't know How is he Okay There we go I
didn't wait should I think I personally I think personally
this is a triple support angle because it makes him like
actually he makes him worthless like that one out of there
yeah wait did he oh wait where did he go I didn't even
realize he was mag I'm bro I've been fighting my fucking
inner demons right now with the spider man I do not have
time to go I got you I got you I need you to get me too very
soon pretty easy yeah why is he playing like that because
it's he's ranked he's stupid it's ranked he's fucking stupid
there you go he's fucking crazy no oh my Does it know?
Oh, we have to walk.
Okay.
Oh, I'm backing up.
180.
We're 172.
Get in, get in, get in!
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
He dies.
It does not look like...
Okay.
I don't think Oh please It's okay We got a lot It's alright
I guess I was like Bro that spy mask was some TF2 shit And
he fucking got stuck in the wall That That's some Car that's
some cast occurs right there come back yeah yeah pretty
impressive oh my god i see the spider-man nice thing thing
thing one why do you want behind oh nice who the fuck was he
ulting there with pawn can't for me i don't even know who
the fuck all right i'm not too i'm gaming oh that is an
insane pull they poured it back up back up oh god oh god
it's just i got pulled here we go wait where did my did my
club she just okay she could have thrown that orb to me she
threw the orb to herself i'm going at the rocket Right
still!
What are you?
Oh my god, I didn't realize the Spider-Man was coming over.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize.
That was my bad story.
I threw that.
Oh, I threw that.
Do it, do it, do it, do it, bro.
Do it, do it, do it.
Cover me, cover me.
Oh, that's fire.
I didn't think the...
and play for group play for group don't rush don't rush
don't rush that's a huge all right there oh my god they
can't America out though oh no that's so unlucky yeah oh no
that's so unlucky yeah oh man I didn't see if I I should
have just alted that but I was just like Like, I didn't
think the Spider-Man was going to fucking fight me with the
rocket.
He distracted me there.
It's okay.
He did say four more games.
And now, it's still going to be four more games.
It's okay.
It's now still going to be four more games.
I trolled there.
I thought that.
I won't say, like, I take full blame.
I but it's all right I messed up that one flight yeah all
right yeah I know for sure I played perfectly yeah I think
you know what we could use some more some more passion you
know you know to be yeah about the game but no but it's like
you're like at 200% passion so like you're there already
covering for it for me you know like you're saying like life
stealing your passion right now no no no i'm saying like
you're like you're already at 200 so if i give my passion in
it might like overflow you know what if we like you can give
it a shot though like that low keep like would be tough
it'll be like it'll be like what wait what thoughts
the passion the passion yeah okay all right i'll give you
i'll give you like a hundred and one how of that
okay i'll give you a hundred and one percent passion the
next game okay i'll take that yeah yeah yeah
he'll start avoiding me after this I think I played
perfectly with you W 1%
Alright don't worry we got this We got this guys I'll give
him like 101% and that means Like I'll say I'll be like I'll
be like I'll They'll be like That's my 1% I usually don't
say it But then in game I'll be like out first, guys.
That's the one for set.
I'm helping.
Ventro.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Cons.
See?
That's calming.
That's, I'm literally calming.
I think he saw my tournament like yesterday.
He's like, why is this she like this in rank?
I fucking booger bash.
I'm like, I need help.
Edgy, edgy, edgy.
Moxie, help me.
Maxip getting dumb.
He's like, who else?
He's like, that's crazy.
Why is she like this in rain?
Like, like when Crook beats up my friend.
No, no, no.
I don't need it.
No.
Like, why isn't she like this in rank?
That's true.
Why isn't she?
Rank is the vibe, so.
Alright.
What are we doing?
Or when I go...
Yeah, I'm like a different person.
here.
I rock it.
Oh yeah, no, I should rock it.
This person literally has Lord, like, Lord++ on cloak.
I mean, if I really want to win, I go low key and then get
double cloak up, because that shit is cancer.
That shit sucks.
I'll give people a jump pack Nah, the J3 tournament I don't
even know if it's still going on
Apparently you're supposed to be four invited captains But
then it became three I don't even know how that happened
Blade and Magic The comp I think that is a winning comp See
this is what I mean I'm like how the fuck do I get practice
In like pro tournaments When like Oh no.
Oh no.
One there back right?
We killed my rocket.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, we're still alive.
Holy shit.
We still...
How?
Save me.
Oh my god, no.
It's dive.
It really is.
Oh my god.
Okay, I didn't mean I want practice now.
I really did not mean that the tournament is over.
The tournament is over.
You were trained.
Where is this?
I said I didn't mean I want it now.
The grind never stopped.
Oh, no.
You're welcome.
Digimode, I'm gonna need you to lock in, Vucker.
Why do you...
Yo, yo, yo, are you...
Why do you sound like that now?
What?
What does he mean, Vucker?
There's not no new mic.
A new mic's not gonna get changed.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I love you, bro.
Whoa!
These are not here.
Yeah, yeah.
These are all me.
Uh, okay.
Do it.
I'll first.
Wait, I'll first.
There, that's the 1%.
Yay.
This is how I carry things.
Alright, me first.
I'm gonna throw it.
Kill this thing.
That's a cloud.
Yeah, oh, goodbye.
That's a lot.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
That's a lot.
What is, what, what is, what is going on?
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking.
Oh, my res is so far.
Well, that's unfortunate.
I broke the res.
Oh my god.
All right, there we go.
See, look at that.
Don't see.
I, I calm.
There's no way he's going to come for me here.
we kill point thing one thing one i'm helping i'm helping
i'm helping he doesn't know he i'm he doesn't know i got him
he still doesn't know uh is it crazy to still go aggro with
ham i think we still go aggro all right let's go
Oh, Emma's low, too.
Go half.
Kill thing, kill thing.
Benjamin, Benjamin.
Wait, see half.
Diddy, diddy.
Diddy, next, see next.
All right, there you go.
See it?
1% effort.
Look at me go.
Look at that.
I was like, that 1%?
Yeah.
I'm helping.
Look at it.
See?
That's all I have to say.
Me, first thing, though.
The 1% the dirty.
You're winning now.
No, I think...
No, no.
That's not it.
I would have won regardless.
I...
I have won without having to do the 1% job.
Nah.
I don't think so.
Oh, only real players have zero deaths.
Alright, nice.
I think I've been three, two, one.
Oh, we still have Kiyoka.
This is space here.
I'm on their backline.
Oh my god, he is.
He is.
He's not lying about that.
Oh my.
Okay, nice nice.
We have.
Oh, I got all cooldowns out of them more.
Oh, fuck.
That's fine.
We're still healthy.
way they see this there's no way oh you're coming with me oh
you're coming with me too that card sucker we've blade we've
blade uh blade group combos there you that second card see i
told you no one was gonna see that res it's my i've done all
right at the moment i can I'm gonna get off the cart now
Nice, see?
Look at that, see?
See, that's all you need See?
1% is all you need Anybody like Jeff to rest or something?
What's going on?
Like, bro, it's literally Celestial 2, Celestial 1 Bro, this
is like...
Yeah, and...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You can't be saying that, brother.
You can't be saying that.
Why?
I am 1% new in one name.
Bro, bro, bro, bro, bro.
Tell me why.
You're Sigalord.
What do you mean?
Yeah, but I don't remember if he's the jet player that
everyone hates or the jet player that everyone is scared of.
There's too many jet players.
I don't remember.
30 seconds before you attack Get ready The reality of Jeff
Could be I don't know he's playing Thor So I know He is
playing Thor so I can't tell Which Jeff What flavor of Jeff
is he They're one and the same You know like for when the
season started For like the first week player was a scarlet
witch and jeff player and no one knew who he is who he was
because he was on an alt account he literally was on like
pro lob like the oh my god he's not scared the pro lobbies
just throwing scarlet witch out and having like a positive
win rate
mother backline in five so the bad part is that Okay, I
wouldn't like if somebody shot the squid.
It's okay, we have Rose.
No, I'm stalling these guys, aren't...
Alright.
But what?
The orbs!
I think she's got the orbs.
Look at that, look at that, uh...
Rocket, rocket.
Oh, I should have thrown my orbs.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I didn't.
He doesn't know I was trying to DPS instead of healing him.
But he doesn't.
Oh my god, what he doesn't know won't hurt him.
That's a fast name reel, I will have to say.
You cannot tell me.
This is not late.
Almost ready.
Very low, Elo.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
I'm okay.
I didn't say anything because I knew I would lift.
I knew I was gonna lift.
They weren't at his time.
Oh.
No, not there.
I think I made this kind of mad.
This is real firepower.
Get the rocket.
All right, let's go.
Fuck these guys.
I swear.
Isn't this rocket a streamer?
I don't think so.
All right.
We're five.
We're so safe.
Like nothing to worry about.
Oh.
Alright, there's no way they'll see this.
Alright, thank God I threw the old...
There's no way they see me here, right?
Whoa!
I'm fine.
Oh shit!
I got greedy!
I got so greedy!
I wanted to chop that tree down.
So yeah, I have a plan.
They're down too.
They have no supports, actually.
Why would anyone want to border when they can enjoy chaos?
There we go.
I'm going away.
All right.
And then I swap.
Watch this.
He's literally like breathing on one foot.
This guy's so low.
He doesn't know I'm here.
He doesn't know I'm here now.
That's spotty man.
That spotty man can't...
Doesn't know.
That spotty man doesn't know.
I'm so safe.
Get him here, get him here, get him here.
I'm ready.
It's so safe.
Oh shit!
Wait, where's my...
Okay.
Let's hope the...
Oh, that's... that's awkward.
You think my heels getting to them?
It is.
All right.
I'm letting my cloak build.
Oh, not technically not throwing.
Don't worry.
Classic ricochet.
Watch this.
It hits them perfectly.
Oh, look at that.
Oh my God.
That's actually so fucking, you know what?
Let's go.
Okay, nice.
My little...
Oh, I should have fucking threw that res for him.
Are we throwing?
No.
No way.
See, he still doesn't know.
See, I totally do.
No!
He found me!
Oh!
All right All right, it's okay.
Yeah, it was a one beat.
Okay, it's not okay I got shoved in the locker That's okay
Unfortunately guys, unfortunately All right, it's okay more
XP you get more.
God.
Oh God.
He's back It's okay.
I I got you.
I got you
I helped in that just remember No, they're not in a group.
Never mind.
No bother Once I walk out of spawn, though, I'm so scared to
get out of the shadows.
You won't know I'm in this here, right?
Surely he wouldn't know.
Surely.
Surely he doesn't know I'm in here.
Oh, he got this.
He doesn't know I'm right here.
Literally Thanos.
Holy shit.
All right.
Here we go.
There we go.
We're good.
I'm just in the shadows.
He doesn't.
See, he doesn't know I'm right here.
Are they going to play Mag or is that like...
He doesn't know I'm right here.
You're just not allowed to play Mag.
That's okay.
He didn't grab me.
As long as the Spider-Man didn't grab me, we're fine.
See, right here.
We're so safe.
I hope that whale's not here.
I really do.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
We got this.
We got...
See, we're still alive.
Alright, we can kill this one guy.
that's fine no need to use any other it's the world i'm
gonna i'm gonna hit this okay all right let's go no whoa
whoa whoa whoa there we go look at that break it break it i
think mile broke there you go away from my my fucking one
shot all right look why did you pull him into the sky We
double support.
Oh, did accident.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
Oh, fuck.
He doesn't.
No, he lost me.
No, he didn't lose me.
I was like, I did it.
I was like, guys, I did it.
Yeah, you're kind of dead.
I thought I thought I was so smart I thought I had the
smartest escape route of my all right it's okay 81 take some
space here not me though I got both sports one in this
little room Um...
Are they gonna be five?
Play for our girdle.
Like, if we lose this, we come back with TP and girdle.
Okay.
It's okay.
Can you TP, uh, cloak?
Even if it's so much support, we only need one ult.
Just TP.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
You're quick.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
I jumped through.
I touched, I touched.
What the?
What the fuck is that?
That was not bad.
Oh my god.
Which one is our all?
Oh.
My god.
I think maybe if it wasn't.
a fucking we got yeah we got stuffed into a blender i think
if it was not blender we didn't get blended it might have
been a might have been better he was like it's okay there's
no such thing as a there's no such thing as a bad tp no
where is the club where is she
Oh my god, we have close-ups.
I'm not sure about that TP.
It's like, I'm not as the poor I am.
Yeah, I was just like, mmm, that...
I felt like that might have been a little...
Oh god, that's so bad for me.
That's actually so bad for me I didn't even see Oh yeah
that's right That's right Spider-Man That's on you That's
right Spider-Man Killing me was no use Oh shouldn't have
targeted me Now your team's dead That's fucking karma That's
karma lose that.
That's fucking right.
That's what he gets.
He won the battle but lost the war.
I was just the bait.
That was the fucking bait.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Easiest game of my life.
That 1% that 1% is getting different, right?
Yeah, yeah, that.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Yeah.
Exactly.
That 1% won us that game.
That 1% I ult.
I ult first.
I think that's all I said.
I don't even remember what else I said in that game.
It felt like each percent is a word.
That one Yeah, they got a moral booster Like, holy fuck how
could they kill Or like that Alright, off to dancing Who's
that?
Times Square isn't the same Look, nobody dances No more
Everyone just wants to clobber Everyone just wants to
clobber Where are my dancers?
even do it oh my god look at how tiny they are don't worry
little guys i'll give you a show
put it me there you go there you go i hope you guys have a
great date i'm pretty sure they're on a date right now and
i'm giving them a show is this a rabbit um i am the hired
entertainment for this date that they're having together.
He's just serenading his e-pal.
And I'm like, hey guys!
Who wants to dance?
Trying to, yeah, I'm just...
One of them hired me to give them the loyalty test to see,
like, what they'll do, you know?
It's the loyalty test.
loyalty test.
What will you do if this hot ass came over here and started
twerking?
Oh, is this a new map?
Yes.
I've been playing this at once.
I've been playing for the whole thing.
Oh my god.
Alright.
This map better be so peak.
New soundtrack.
Apparently the third point, I only made it to it once
because every game is so easy, but Um, oh my god, bro, shut
up!
Dude, holy shit.
Oh my god.
How are you banning Squirrel Girl?
Oh my god, they're flirting.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, let's call them out.
Who's on the other team, bro?
Who's on the other team?
Why are they banning Squirrel Girl?
Oh, thank God.
That's not good.
Oh, they found out.
They streamed Snappy.
Did they have a Squirrel Girl player?
They did the magic?
Fuck that guy.
And then they kissed.
And I get to watch for free.
Maybe we should, like, low-key let him play, no?
i'm trying to play venom it's a hard counter oh my god it's
like they have their own little we're gonna leave gambit
open for fucking score it's like they're having their little
own conversation together it's like will they won't they
gambit's open it's over all right you'll need a top-notch
team to win this one all right you got it i'll go ahead oh
my god we didn't ban gambit or loki Oh my god!
I agree with the statement.
How do we not bet?
How do we not bet even Loki?
Let me turn it.
Yeah, let me pull up my keyboard real quick.
One second.
How?
We could have at least bet Loki.
Oh my god.
It's gonna be Gambit.
How do we not even...
Bad Loki!
Like, it's fine, we don't- It's fine, we don't have fucking
Gambit, but Loki!
Wait, the soundtrack is fire!
Oh, shit.
I fucking hate this map.
This is the second time I play this map, and I hate it.
This map sucks.
How much time I got?
8 seconds?
You got 5 seconds!
All right, here we go.
All right, good to go.
There's so much shit in the way, bro.
I hate it.
Oh, my God.
It's the school bus.
It's my school bus.
Wait, it is.
Fucking hate this, man.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I need to...
They're exploring.
He's exploring.
He's like, oh, my God.
This little explorer tab.
Oh, my.
We actually...
That's good.
Why is this Loki doing here?
Rick lamps, Rick lamps.
What the fuck?
I was gonna say, how did this Loki get here?
How is this Loki still alive?
What is Loki doing there?
That is sick.
We're only halfway?
Um.
Hold on.
How do you live?
Okay, for a second.
Please.
How do you live?
Oh!
Did I just pull both?
All right.
This should be fine.
Wait, where's my gambit?
Alright.
I think we should uh, gambit all early and then we can combo
next.
So we all come back.
Alright.
Uh, you first.
Yeah, can we copy and do it right now?
Oh wait, me?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm fucking getting it.
Okay, I shall copy.
Oh wait.
Maps close range.
I'll watch.
I'll wait.
I'll look at the shield.
How can we do it now?
All right.
Go, go, go.
I'm going to big spin.
Big spin, big spin.
I do not want to get near them.
After...
I don't know about you guys.
I'm so paranoid.
I'm so...
All right.
I'm so paranoid about fucking going aggressively.
After what happened to me...
I don't want to go in aggressively.
Oh, bye.
We give it?
Oh, they see like we don't need it.
We don't need it.
We got it.
All right, it's fine.
We made it.
We got a game of starter.
That was nothing for a god.
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
He's not looking at me, right?
All right, there's this.
Oh, wait.
This is where the...
Oh, is this where the car goes?
This is where the car goes.
Okay, I'm going to put one on here.
One on the other bus, and then I'll...
All right.
There we go.
They won't know which one's the real.
Look, he's doing it for the vibes!
Can we stop Metaslave in here?
But that Metaslave is all I'm about.
I'm all, I'm all.
Jesus Christ, that guy got deleted so fast.
I was...
Oh my god, okay.
I bet we got every final.
Wait, that guy's one.
Take out one of our supports.
Wait.
They don't need me.
Thank God.
That's great.
They don't need me.
We got, we got that copy.
Why don't we copy early?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Red point is very tall and very big, so you gotta stand
inside of it.
All right.
I assume...
You're ready.
Once they walk.
I gotta leave.
I leave.
See, this is why This is why I don't Yep This is why I don't
go straight in This is why I don't go straight in anymore As
Gambit This is This is why I've learned I've learned every
time Every time somebody fucking gambit us It's like Kill
the gambit I think they got the I'm pretty sure they thought
I the other Gambit was me and then they rushed him.
Thank God that's what I like to see.
They were like get him and that was actually the guy I
copied.
Okay let's shoot.
I mean you can ult whenever we're just farming.
Oh I'm almost ready Gambit give me like 10 more.
Oh yeah.
Really close.
I don't have um Really?
Okay.
Alright.
Kill her, kill her, kill her, kill her, kill her!
Oh.
Yeah.
That's why I'm always scared.
Jesus.
You know what'd be cool?
Alright.
I don't know, no more.
I don't know if this cop's working.
Oh, that's...
Can we please play silo?
Oh!
Like, bullshit on these guys.
I don't play silo?
Alright, you want me to play?
Alright, here we go.
It's okay, I have...
We have coffee.
Whoa, the music.
Hold on.
Watch out for sure.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go!
I fucking knew it.
I fucking, I told you.
I- Yeah, better.
I fucking told you.
Every time!
I'm TP.
We'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
Every fucking time!
I'm TP.
every time I no longer push I no longer push with Gambit I'm
just a little okay I don't know where their spawn is bro I
didn't get it bro yo I'm on Invis I have Please!
Oh my god, yeah!
That's okay, we won that.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Did you see that?
I juke the sidewalk.
She's like, where did she go?
Where did she go?
I like that a lot.
But then I moved.
Because I got scared.
I got scared.
I was just like, I'm just kidding.
Go look at the cart real quick.
Alright, now...
Oh yeah, this has become the duck.
Wait, does it heal?
Wait.
Oh my god, wait.
That's actually...
That seems broken.
That seems so broken.
Not gonna lie.
Wait, is that broken?
Wait,
you don't count when you're on the top of the cart?
That's so dumb.
Yeah.
Oh, my.
Oh, wait.
Yo, he's killed everybody.
Alright.
You know what?
Let's go!
I didn't get it.
I really use it.
Alright.
I'll wait for the real one.
Oh, alright.
Alright.
We're going to be lamps.
Yo, thanks.
You guys should do this?
Just one, no one.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, we have real...
We have real Gambit.
Come on.
I'm almost there, guys!
I don't have a DB.
Walk, walk, walk.
I'm so close!
That stupid fucking Ark is still there, too.
That's...
I don't know if that got anybody, but...
No, I died.
No, I got the gun.
No healers.
Uh, we don't have this.
Did we have TP yet?
No!
In 10 seconds.
I should have it, hopefully.
No, I don't talk to people in rank.
I haven't.
Stay on, I can storm for TP if you die on, die on, die on Oh
my god, you need to die on, you can get Skynite No!
The current score is 2, 2, 0 It's okay.
I just...
You know, I think I play perfectly.
I don't know if I should keep playing Loki.
I'll keep playing Loki.
They have Moon Knight, but I'm still gonna do it.
run triple support no notes no no notes so far no notes no
notes no notes oh he doesn't want to play gambit but who was
you want mantis ziga bro why would i play either those two i
can play jet i could be a gambit wily unreliable go go wild
let me let me double support with toky Let's go wild.
Go fucking wild.
I'm technically Gambit.
I literally copy a Gambit.
I'm Gambit like 10% of the time.
There we go.
Can you even see me?
I know, right?
It's crazy.
I don't know how we keep getting matched up together in
these games.
It's like the wildest luck ever.
where do we play here and we don't get like instant rolled
this is so close no one knows i think i think like oh this
is usually hard to break i know it's wild is he okay walk in
front of me i'll i'll try and carry you
oh my god he's fine he's so healthy he's so Healthy!
We don't need the...
Oh my god, he's not healthy though.
Oh, we might have been a little bit too cocky there.
I think everybody's fine, right?
Not him though.
But I'm fine.
You better pick it up.
Out here, out here.
Three, two, one.
Let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Boom, boom, boom.
You have to get to get it.
Thanks.
All right, I'm okay.
I just let them heal that.
All right, here we go.
I don't need to heal too much now.
I have a feeling
Oh, where is she going?
Wow!
Ha-ha!
I'm fine.
I'll just stay over here.
That's where I don't go in no more.
You see that?
If I went in, that I knew, I knew that siloed, that siloed
was kind of up the moment I dashed in.
I was like, Fuck that shit.
I'll be here in my little corner.
I don't trust anybody.
Oh my.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna die on point.
Yo, shoot him back!
I was literally gone.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck am I going?
Bro, I don't know this map at all.
Nothing.
There we go.
Oh.
All right.
We pulled it in.
I got my ult.
All right.
Here we go.
Yo, everybody walked in the, uh, care, care, care.
He's gonna clobber it.
Jump back through.
Go through other side.
Go through the top.
Come through, jump through, jump through.
I don't, I don't.
Killer, killer, killer, anti, anti, anti.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
Well, cameras are dead.
I don't know what's going on.
on wait what the why did you leave I was so alive why did I
could fit him why why I was still alive how do these things
do he's like see he's like peace I don't want to He's like,
I gotta keep my KD8.
Maybe I can go through?
Okay.
There we go.
I fucking do it!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm so fast!
I fucking knew it!
I fucking knew that was gonna happen!
What can I do?
I think I need you to get a big ult here, Bear.
Every damn time.
Go that game, Bear.
It's just 1v6.
Every triple tank we are.
Technically, we're triple tank.
I'm gonna let him heal.
I'll let him heal.
I'll let him heal so you can grab all All right, here we go
All right, she should have it All right I see you I see you
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't see you.
I should have fucking I'm so sad.
I didn't that was my bad I sort of threw that I tunneled in
I tunneled in on the fucking on the sidewalk so badly that
like I did not I did not care about anything else I was like
I see you I hope you see you big climber big climber Oh my
god.
Oh my god, I'm just gonna die here.
Just kidding.
With uh...
Can we kill me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yo, yo, before we jump through the portal.
Copy me.
Don't, don't portal like that.
Copy me on the right and we just gambit all.
We win.
We have time.
We time.
Don't rush it.
Copy me.
Let's go, go, go, go.
Oh yeah.
Entity, Entity.
Oh my god, it's you and me.
That's unlucky.
Oh!
I feel like...
I don't know.
I think I should...
I don't know if I should swap.
The Moon Knight isn't doing shit.
We'll see.
But we do have...
Okay, we're not doing triple tank no more.
Alright.
What?
I feel like you should swap only because they are running
Moon Knight, but like...
I don't...
I'll save my dashes.
It's like that side...
Yeah, I'm just gonna swap to Invis after.
Say bye, say bye, see you.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm saving mine for the match.
You need to live.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, yeah.
I know, I know.
Sealing our bag is one of your...
Yeah, that sucks.
He's just... I'm just gonna invis.
I think I should just invis.
Yeah.
Big, big!
I think invis is worth it.
If it's like, they don't farm that and then I can fend for
myself or Scylla.
We're gonna lose.
I don't ever send.
Don't ever send.
You only want support.
I'm reloading.
Reloading.
Oh my god, it's so far.
you're ready to pull tight because you have no map you can
allow yeah everybody needs to play there i can't hear you oh
i forgot about the map
nice good pick yep there you go that's the question go
through go through
yeah all right i knew it i knew going in this was the play i
figured like jesus 50 oh my god yeah i had a feeling i was
like i don't think i should play doki i feel like the moon
night is doing too much it's doing way too much yo what do
you think of the map doki bro i i but I fucking hate the new
map okay it's because it's it's so orange it's actually
really close you don't like it bro it's just it's I like the
intensity oh my god wait sorry I'm in time square I gotta
leave time square music too it's really good bro it's just
it's so orange it's it's okay and okay to be fair it's like
it's so confusing There's so many rooms, too.
I really like...
I think it'll mix things up, and that's what I like.
Yeah, what you like better.
I think it's like it'll change some stuff.
I like the way there are...
I like the last point.
The last point's cool.
Like, you can put your clones in the last...
Like, on the bouncy thing, too.
The bouncy thing is really cool.
I have to agree.
But that also doesn't count as being on point, which is kind
of stupid, in my opinion.
If you're up top, it doesn't count.
You could see nine really.
Yeah, I think like, because those are my second time on that
map.
And like, I remember like, there's, on the second point,
there's so many rooms that just lead nowhere.
It's so confusing.
Like, I think the walk back, too, to the point is very long.
I feel like.
I'm not sure if it's because there's so many rooms or just
the fact that it just feels longer.
I think it's because we just don't know the map yet.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, that's it.
Dude, I walked into the fucking wall.
I was backing up and I left the wall.
it's so weird what's it called areas where you can't shoot
your gun through that's actually good encourages brawl
fights which is really good i love that wait what you're
doing there were rooms you can't shoot it i can't shoot out
of there's little areas that block heat and block damage oh
my god yellow things that's why i couldn't kill the siloed
oh that makes so much more sense now I shot a silo like
three times and I was like why is this she taking damage
it's good for brawls because you can play more oh my god
that makes so much more sense now I was just like there's no
way he doesn't take one damage like I didn't even notice
that it's just like that that makes so much more sense so
that's uh also deadly kitten thank you for the 300 videos
thank you thank you now we need to win i like two more games
oh my god get me out what if it's three more games no no no
no what if
oh man that would be so unfortunate also I just realized
Kingsman's Twitch account is Kingsman 265 underscore Twitch
I don't think this I don't think my buddy knows that he can
claim a better username now that he's partner he he can
literally be Kingsman right now yeah Probably not.
I think, honestly, you should just...
You should rip it with that.
That should be his bread.
It's his identity now.
Kingsman265 underscore Twitch.
Bro, you could...
Literally, you could...
The worst part?
I can't even claim Doki.
Because it's a actual Rainbow Six Siege Pro.
Like, he was there first.
What do you mean, Imperator?
I was solo-keeling, and then, like, you just asked me.
I didn't take your duo.
Your duo...
Your duo went hose before bros.
That's not my fault.
That's Mr. Kingsman 2695 underscore Twitch to you.
My bro.
Alright, let's go.
I feel cloaky today.
Or bros before hoes.
Either works, honestly.
I don't know if Imperator is a ho or not.
Imp, are you a ho?
Or are you a bro?
I'm a bro.
I'm a boy ho.
Oh, so yeah, your bro went bros before hoes.
He chose...
He chose the bro.
Can I get a booster please?
You can't ask that.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, Kingsman did pick the bro.
I think I'll get it.
I got it.
Thank you.
Damn.
You gotta find a main piece, bro.
You can't be hoeing it up your entire life.
Oh my god.
There's a Wolverine camping and I'm fucking...
I'm noveling, but I'm gonna die.
Yeah, yeah, no, you can't.
Bro, you got to sell that one, then.
That guy and, uh, be downy, I think.
I think that could be good here.
Maybe, like, Phoenix.
What the?
Where's my...
Clicking his wall, by the way.
He's gonna be moving.
Alright, here we go.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Oh my god!
Everything is fine.
They have no mag.
Wait.
That's my dream.
Oh, my God.
He's coming closer.
He's coming so much closer.
I don't know.
Jeff and Cloakio is a little...
I'm gonna go wallbreak Iron Man.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
I got a little worried.
I...
I really did.
I got a little worried there.
Ah, we can go in, right?
Yeah, fuck it.
Oh, I'm going back.
I can see he's going to grab me.
I can feel it.
I risked.
You ain't fooling me.
I know what you are.
I knew he was going to grab me.
Wait, now he doesn't want to play me.
I'm about I'm leaving She learned
Alright here we go Let's go Yeah I Oh there we go I was
gonna say I don't think Jeff is gonna work here only because
I don't think this guy is a pro Jeff player so that Oh don't
worry I got this Oh no Okay, I did say, what if it's three
more games?
Oh, did I accidentally jinxed him?
Ooh, that is my bad.
You know, I never...
I didn't think that it would actually be three games.
We gotta use it because it's been three minutes, so we gotta
just go with it.
Classic.
Look, when I said it could be three games, I didn't think it
could actually be He's still behind by the way.
He's like getting hardcore staggered right now.
Is he still getting staggered?
There we go.
Almost had one.
That's my bad.
It might turn into a four.
You're a jab, jab, jab, jab.
One.
That wolf is so low.
Please, we just gotta heal each other.
Oh my god, it's fine.
That's right!
Boom!
Please don't grab me.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I am so healthy.
That's right.
There you go.
We're good.
We're so healthy.
Oh yeah, we're so healthy.
I knew we were gonna be so healthy.
Alright.
He knows and we all still be another 50 games.
Well, I need our guy.
I need him to heal.
So, um, he needs to build up like now.
Come on, go build your up.
I help.
Oh.
That's awkward.
We're fine.
Goodbye.
oh my god you're so you're alive just keep me alive i
understand we get right we get right i don't understand i
trust my support why are we playing cs going to stop it are
you killing it's okay that's it oh I don't think anyone saw
the doorbell line It's alright Things are okay
Alright it's okay It's understandable I would panic too in
that situation Jesus Christ I am scared That's actually huge
Okay how am I supposed to heal you if you're fucking jumping
around like a little no i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
all right
all right there you go he can't hurt you no more we have he
can't hurt you no more nice it's okay that spider-man can't
hurt us i got him Oh my god, I don't know if I can, oh Oh,
please tell me, please tell I was like, I'm not going to
press tab So please tell me he has all Unfortunately he did
not Oh, he's going to grip him Oh, wait, do we not have
strange portal?
We need to get some space now, Bono You need to go Dude,
don't we have TP?
They're going to cancel you have to We have to fight it.
We have to fight it.
Don't worry.
I got him.
There we go.
Oh,
it's just me.
All right, nice.
It's just me.
Honestly, we- One, one, one.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh, that's unfortunate.
What is that fucking crosshair?
She's under my toes, man.
I can't!
Oh my god.
You that guy from that Zaza video, bro?
No, no, no.
You're clearly not playing for money, bro.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, I'm going to play to win here.
Thoughts on Sponald?
He's like, wait a minute.
Aren't you that guy?
Aren't you that rep from the me?
What do we got?
What are you calling a raccoon?
All right.
It's like, oh.
Yo, okay.
We can't play fucking, we cannot play Strange.
We're doing that now.
Like, in the Sponald.
We got to go on Benjamin Group.
Oh, we got to do.
We actually, uh, is this i don't remember i think it's uh
joki you play you play uh good right can you take life from
me all right yeah yeah yeah go all right there we go yeah i
feel like i should go mantis then all right here we go i
thought mantis bad with this type of comp but let's try it
out here we go care of the wolf he's your biggest problem
He's dead, man.
He's going to live in my nightmares.
Frank, well, I got you, cool.
Play me.
Two, one.
I have many faces.
All right.
What the?
Please don't die already.
Okay.
I'm like, how?
Oh.
Oh
My god, we I don't know We go magic screw this Yeah, I'm
like guys I really want to play Phoenix here Alright, go
Phoenix then go Phoenix Go Phoenix I'll go into it Better
win the game the vibes i don't know oh no no i don't know i
don't think you guys are playing for 40k right now it
doesn't seem like it doesn't feel like it right now
can't cross this line there you go
all right that's i don't think we cat.
I don't think so, either.
Hey, but we got a cool ass portal.
Wait, why will we be playing more hammer 40k in rivals?
I don't see you're right.
You're right, guys.
Honestly, Honestly, why does everyone keep talking about
Warhammer?
I don't understand.
Break the Scrooge's wall.
Like, always out.
Control solution.
One more.
All right, let's go.
Don't rush.
Don't rush it.
We pre-copied, so we can go after.
Okay.
Oh, another copy.
What are you waiting?
Okay, look.
I didn't get healed.
I think I played that perfectly.
I think I play that perfectly Because I didn't get healed
there
Honestly I
had to reload Oh my god okay Alright Like I said I play that
perfectly I told you guys I play that perfectly
All right, there we go.
Look at that see see guys see I play that perfectly See look
at that
Look at that!
Look at that.
Maybe save lamps for it if you can.
Wait, lamps for your wood.
I don't have a ball for the Wolverine.
Alright, here we go.
He's one in the past.
Let's hope that...
Oh.
All right All right, no laps for 24 seconds
All right Let's do that for two more minutes.
Oh god.
The wall is coming two more minutes.
Yes now.
Yeah Time to vanish.
He's half.
He's sitting and eating my damage.
All right.
Let's hope he's right there.
He's right there.
Careful I've canceled Wait, come on, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
Go on the dog!
Alright, this is bad, I use lamps.
Oh, he got me.
I think I lived that.
Yeah, you killed that, you killed that.
We have strange dog coming up.
Okay, guys.
I am ready to put on a shot!
I wish it was!
I thought he was here!
I thought him was here!
I thought it would work.
I dropped off.
Doesn't matter bro.
Taking it up, taking it.
Oh my.
I'm trying!
Final score.
One, two, two.
Oh man, it almost worked.
I flinched.
I really did.
I don't even know.
I almost got it I almost It almost worked I think I'm going
to get off I didn't say it Oh my god
all right all right good night uh good night jesus now he
knows i think that's been a good i think those been good
games i think i played it perfectly
i think i played it perfectly guys
you sure did and he will never come back That won't stop me
from matching it up.
You can't avoid the queues.
Now that I know, I'll play at this time.
All according to plan.
I'm so mad that I can't duel people.
I can't fucking duel people while I'm queuing.
Why can't I beat up the bronze and silvers?
When I lose a game, I mean, like, time to queue up some
clobbering club.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the raid.
I did... End game.
End game, by the way.
End game.
Thank you for the raid, Kingsman.
I hope you get one above all tomorrow.
Three more games.
And it could be four more games.
And maybe five more games.
But eventually, you could get there.
I believe.
I...
Well, welcome.
Hello, everybody.
For those who are new here and everything, a lot of people
are new here because a lot of people uh might not be vtuber
watchers but my name is dokeeper i usually stream on youtube
and whenever i get mad whenever sorry whenever i get mad or
or like i have extra time i do like uh spontaneous streams
on twitch uh but yeah please feel free to check me out on
youtube um that's where my main channel is where i do most
of my streams i play rivals as a side thing so i am a
variety streamer and then whenever i have time i i just
queue up rivals because it's like my free time game um and
yeah you want to check me out other stuff i follow me on
twitter is that's where i announce whenever i stream on
twitch yeah it's my second job i clock in on my second job
I actually enjoy the game.
I play it as my cool down period.
But then when I'm not cooling down, and then I finally, I
keep forgetting that weekend queues are like a special breed
of players.
And then, because and then I got like, it's crazy.
For the Kingsman viewers, it's crazy.
Like this guy was like mentioning Kingsman and stuff.
And then like, he was like flaming me.
and because like the other support was like what like he was
flaming the other support and i was like yeah the other
support like i was just like all right yeah they didn't
really perform that great and the other support who was chat
bad told his duo to like try and get him to flame me instead
because he's like um it's not me but it's dokey bird's fault
and i was like um excuse me like i was just like what the i
see like yeah and i was just like what the the fuck why did
you like pawn it off on me i didn't say nothing i i didn't
even say anything and and i'm like bro if you were chat bad
this something is wrong too like if you are chat bad maybe
you are the problem because i've never been chat bad since
this game came out yeah and then and then the guy started
like using kingsman to blame me and i thought it was And
then I ended up playing with Kingsman today, and I was like,
to my chat, I was like, to that guy that flayed me, I will
play with all your Idols to make you feel like shit.
Like, like somehow, like, somehow it was such a funny
coincidence, because this Idol was like Kingsman too.
And I was like, I will play with all your Idols.
out of spite now so you'll see me everywhere now that's
right you're gonna see me everywhere can't fucking avoid me
but yeah anyway i do play a lot of fps i i was first for
those the new viewers i was first known as like an fps
player so i was apex predator and apex legends and i was uh
top five and Overwatch 1 and 2.
And then Top 500 and Marvel Rivals.
So like, the thing I, what I do is that I get Top 500 in
video, in like games I like and then I stop caring.
Because I'm like, I did it.
I'm just gonna vibe now.
And I hate that vibe.
I used to use the word vibe like, unironically.
And now I can't anymore.
Because the word vibe is gone now.
It's ruined it's it's like ruined now oh yeah and i was
technically top 500 in splatoon 1 2 and 3 because like they
don't really have leaderboards but they do have like the
highest i was the highest rank in splatoon when it first
came out i literally just like and then after i get it i
just stop i just stop playing like playing it as much
because i'm like well i scratched the itch you like it's
like you got it and you're like i don't have a goal anymore
type deal so it's more so like i just play for fun all right
let's see i'll kill time i want to relax wait did they ban
invis oh they did yeah i'm not copying the rocket
yeah job done it's like job done all right time to chill
that's why i haven't like grinding rivals in a long time
because i just like if they don't commit to me i'm also very
busy too behind the scenes so i get so it's like whenever i
get a break i'm like time to boot up marvel rivals we're
doing top five bro high guard is gonna be so frustrating to
play in general i got seems like such a whoa how the fuck
did i lose 80 of my hp i was in the bubble that's triple
yeah that's triple good bye so long i don't think he's
coming back i swear i don't think that guy's coming back it
does i think i think they are all right i oh man he was so
close i do think uh high guard the devs for high guard is
listening for those who didn't know uh they added 5v5 they
actually they added 5v5 they they do listen because they are
an indie studio so but i don't it's like more so like is it
too late oh i live let's go oh i was gonna oh thank god i
did it i would have lost it Yo, Anami, what are you playing?
Fuck.
Yeah, I need you to go Moon Knight now.
I need you to go Moon Knight.
Yeah, they added 5e5 and they like fixed...
I did not realize that they did not have...
It was crouch to toggle.
I did not realize that.
Like it was crouch to toggle.
I was wondering why the fucking game was so slow paced.
It was so hard to crouch.
I did not realize that.
I was like, that makes so much sense now.
You know, fuck it.
Oh, fuck.
Can I charge it a little bit?
No, I lived.
Oh, thank you, Helen.
Holy shit.
My hero.
He took that for the team.
Oh.
I dodged, like, so much.
Oh, but what if...
Oh, wait, where's my team?
That's right.
I'll still live.
That's acting right.
Nothing will kill me.
Oh, that's cool.
All right.
there's any way to shoot it harder no i think oh hey we
killed him nice all right let's go oh my god it's okay wait
he gripped the you can do that i didn't realize you can rip
the storm bolt all right let's go i've never heard someone
this happy in my entire life i don't know most players who
play this game are depressed and that's why i play this as
my free time I Have like streamers being like why isn't she
street?
I would play this off stream People would be like why is she
playing off stream, but like I genuinely just enjoy this
game like I genuinely just think this game is fun It was
like is she live and I'm literally just playing off stream
guys, please.
It's just one There's no way There's no way!
Guys, then I have to kill him!
Bro!
Oh my god!
Bro, there's no way!
Bro, I can save you!
I can save him!
Guys, please!
Please!
Oh my god!
There's no way!
Steve did not kill Jeff!
I had to turn around.
I had to turn around and fucking kill him myself.
What do you mean?
I saw our Magnus and Jeff.
I thought I was the EOMM agent.
I realized everyone was.
Oh my god.
I literally just saw that Magnus to point blank too.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I willingly consensually play this game off stream, by
the way.
But then I stream when I get mad at this game.
But only because of the players, not because of me.
Because I play this game perfectly.
Just don't give it a try, bud.
I mean, I don't know, bro.
Jeff's solo is all joined by himself.
Yeah, that was...
No, that was unfortunate to watch.
I held three of them out there.
Make sure they couldn't come in.
Yeah, I came back and turned around to...
I had the sang and the two healers in front of me.
Just keeping them in the push.
Also, great.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yo, that's...
That...
Yeah.
There we go.
this though it's called the dokey cruise yeah i know it's
called it's like welcome to the it's called elo terrorism
what's the reason that's true that's right there's the elo
terrorism moments also so see plays uh he plays all right we
did it guys oh my god i i don't know if you know this but
there is a there is a he used up has to come over oh my god
and they picked me up and flew back away all right oh please
oh i feel like you just don't play me in here am i sleeping
like i feel like you just like i don't think you play me
like you see the wolf and you're still in the face no you
don't think you just stop dying to a wolf okay that's fine
Why don't you guys want to play things and get unbought?
Like six deaths, eight deaths?
Yeah, I'm having a fun time, team.
Team, let's go.
We can still win this.
Hey, team, it's still possible.
Is he still coming over?
Hello, team.
We're still on board.
You didn't even see me back.
Yay.
I mean, don't lie.
I don't know what you're doing.
this game you are you just like handlers i think um you know
as long as i it wasn't me it wasn't me
um hey guys you didn't blame me and that's a win in my book
you know that's i wasn't part of the problem it wasn't our
fault i don't even know whose fault it is i don't um okay so
who i even lost the plot of the story so who are they
blaming the most uh oh wait how's svp let's go let's go and
it's all that matters you know if king's been queued another
one this it would have been four games i i don't even oh it
was the Tink?
Alright, I'm just a sheep.
I'll listen to what they say.
Wait, he got eight kills.
Okay, I'll grab both the tanks.
You know what?
Yeah, bro dodged a bullet.
Who's church boy?
Who's this cat?
Alright.
Oh, he's climbing.
I don't know who church boy was.
We had a church boy?
Okay.
I'm gonna go to Times Square.
I gotta...
I gotta cool it down after that.
That's surprising.
You know, mock cues are...
Mock cues are wild.
Because I always say this.
If I'm...
Oh, are they on a date?
They're on a date!
Queen Asala!
And I love roast beef!
I wonder...
Hey, cave.
Did anyone order...
Hey, guys.
A dancer?
Yeah?
Are you guys enjoying your little date right here?
Are you...
Are you guys enjoying your little e-date on Discord right
now?
Just hanging out.
Who ordered the dessert here?
I'm here to hope you're to make your date a little bit
better.
you know it's nice it's nice to you know watch them have a
good time you know you know give them a little bit of some
entertainment on the side this is my favorite streamer chat
you know all right here you go
I'm making their day more exciting.
I'm like the...
Yeah, I'm like the...
The entertainment.
Hey, Ruben.
Do you need me to...
You need me to blow some people out of my mind or Bob?
What do you mean?
What do you mean, Ruben?
Alright.
What am I feeling right now?
I'll play this.
Oh, wait.
That's a bad.
I keep forgetting that.
Give you, like, five seconds to pre-pick a character.
Oh, oh, yeah, oh, my title.
I already forgot my title.
My title.
No, it's crazy.
Weekend queues are fucking wild.
We literally, when the screen first started, it was like
four out of four.
It was a three or four.
It was like four out of four games where everyone was just
fucking blaming each other like non-stop.
I was just like, damn.
Like, everyone was just depressed.
And then I'm monetizing their depression right now.
Like, don't worry, buddy.
We're all here for you.
That's my Oshi.
Oh, yeah, he's like the...
He's like the Rule 34 guy now.
Yeah, the true content creation grind.
Ah, yes.
Capitalism.
Mickey Mouse is my Oshi.
He's my idol.
I've always said that.
He's like literally the king of capitalism.
Or should I say, I guess like Disney.
He's the king of capitalism.
One day.
The capitalist mouse.
But I'll get rid of all these.
Oh yeah, I love the skins.
I will save.
I am the consumer that they want.
Like I know what type of game it is.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, Moon, are you fucking crazy?
You're not a tank, bro.
Oh shit, not triple support.
They really want to...
When would I get triple support?
What the fuck?
I'm always the duo supporter, not the triple support.
Not fair.
Get over here.
Go go go go go go.
Where can I score?
Alright.
holy fuck we're going in oh my god we're going in hey you
can use first okay i want to save them all right here we go
i feel like i have not had a really had a game with like
triple support i i know he really hate the voice changer
shit i don't think it's very serious like i think like i
cannot take anyone seriously with the voice senior.
Oh.
I can't use this aggressively too because it's they're like,
run up!
You're not alive.
Unfortunately, not him though.
Not...
Not him, unfortunately.
Wait for me, Moon Knight.
I almost have...
Oh my god, does he actually?
We don't need it.
Just go here, just go here, go here, go here.
Oh, not born again.
Oh god, already?
That's crazy.
Oh my god, it was an attempt.
I really appreciate that.
You tried.
You really...
You really tried, you know.
at least you tried at least you tried it looked really cool
that grew old on that wall it looked so cool like i can't
take anybody seriously they're calming their asses up and
then it's like mickey mouse boys like playing with elvin and
the chick mugs right now i fucking hate it i was gonna be
here
Oh shit, he sees me.
I thought the gamers don't look up.
Oh, don't worry, you're alive.
Jesus Christ, there is my little fucking alt battery right
now.
Oh my god.
My goddamn alt battery.
That's right.
You don't see me over here.
I think this is very dumb to play.
What do you mean?
Oh my...
It's okay.
Take her off.
Bring her off.
Oh my god, it's okay.
We're so healthy.
Oh my god.
We are so healthy!
It's okay.
I have this little hole.
It's so healthy.
There you go.
I don't know.
That just worked.
I live.
Oh my gosh.
I told you, I never lie.
We are healthy.
I told you.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I would lie about that.
If you believe in it, you will live.
Guys.
If you believe that you're healthy, you never have to go see
a doctor again.
In game.
Please see a doctor if you're not feeling it.
In game, by the way, if you are not healthy, please see a
doctor.
And also get health insurance if you're American.
That's how it works.
Yay.
all right but i didn't cough that much today yes i didn't
cough that much today oh we talked to me yeah sure sure
watch this the battle starts in five
the bait and swish bro bro he's like even better even better
that's what he actually wanted where's our our low key okay
our low key is five no more top right no more top right okay
i'm walking in love it oh man he's british stop right stop
right can you break uh squids stop right nice big wall oh
that guy almost died stop right no one i need a fucking
shoot at this i need to pull this guy whenever i can i got
him
There we go.
Fucking stupid idiot.
What the fuck are you going to do?
Fly back?
Double shields!
Yeah.
Yeah, I was like, what is he going to do?
Fly back?
Stupid.
We did it.
We're back.
Yeah.
three more games you bet you know he gave up if he kept
going he could have he could have hit that you know he was
like what at like 11 that's crazy i was streaming for 11
hours
that used to be me
uh let us win i guess that dance club is not what it's like
That's not what it used to be.
I missed the old dance club.
The one where...
Jesus, fucking Chris.
That's a big-ass sidewalk.
Oh, my God.
That's a John.
That's Jeff.
That's so cute.
Oh, my God.
Look at him.
He's business, Jeff.
Don't worry, business, Jeff.
He has a very important meeting.
today don't not do not the shark is that what isn't that
what business is all about I heard trip clubs make majority
of their money from from bachelor parties and business I'm
just I'm just role-playing they should have never given you
guys that evoke permission from the boss to throw it back
yeah that's how they do the business isn't it he ruined the
cuteness he could move that's he stayed it's a look it's not
like a one person thing It's a two-person thing.
He could have left, but he's still here.
It takes two to tango.
Leave that Jeff alone.
He's stayed.
Alright.
What do I feel like now?
You know what?
I worked so hard on Invisible and Invis, I don't play
Rocket.
Now I don't have, I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go back to Zero
Effort.
That's how I deal with it.
If I feel like I work too hard, I just play Rocket to
balance things out.
So I can win with Zero Effort.
Let's brain empty time.
No, Rocket surprisingly meta now.
Can Please, I don't want to play Loki.
That's too much effort.
That's so much.
Yes, but it's like, I'm at the point of time where it's
like, I like winning a lot.
And like, if I get to win with the lowest amount of effort
to play, I'd go for it.
gonna make it harder for myself to win type deal because
like rocket is like the easiest support you can play in
general i mean we're going triple support so now i guess i
have to play mantis
really it is one of the it's one of the i think it's the
easiest support to play out of all of them oh are we running
gambit now or i thought he could he could what are we
running What?
What is this back and forth?
Someone figured this out.
What are we running?
What is this?
What is this back and forth that we're doing?
Me support player.
I can play any support.
I can't play any support.
Just no tank.
Can you gambit?
Give me gambit.
I don't want to gambit.
I don't want to.
I'm just going to get dove.
All right, here we go.
We fucking let...
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so...
angry now because we let Gambit through because of that one
guy was like I can play Gambit so don't ban Gambit like what
was the point we could have banned Gambit this what the fuck
was the point we literally saved Gambit for that one guy and
he's not even I didn't want to play Gambit like we literally
did it for him Holy shit!
Are you see...
Okay, here.
I...
There you go.
I need to...
It would be good a bad gambit.
Yeah, like the guy that was like, I want to play gambit
isn't even playing gambit.
I did not consent to playing gambit.
I wanted to play rocket.
It's fine.
We are undefeatable There we go Why You come out I What do
you mean kid?
Okay, okay, okay, okay It's sort of, okay, I'll come in next
time But it's sort of basic knowledge That Gambit ult first
I I don't didn't think I needed to come then I just thought
In my head that Gambit builders always first, but I guess I
have to calm it now.
Like, why did you, why did I complain instantly?
Why is it up to me to calm that?
True.
I thought...
Alright.
I'm just surprised that it was up to me to be function to be
the one to calm that for us but oh well be calm what
happened to my little effort also yeah i ulted first i did
like i i don't know i did all first my alt was first yeah
she is you guys all right i don't know how that was very
confusing
Oh my god, I'm trying to help her.
I'm fine.
Oh, they were down two supports now.
That sucks.
I got full Dova.
I knew she wasn't gonna live.
I had to, like, leave her.
I was like, I had to leave her, but even then it was a risk.
But anyway, for those who don't know, usually...
This TP point, go group, magnet.
Usually, it is gamma first, no matter what.
You... that's how you rotate it.
That's why I was, like, so confused.
Ready, three, two, one.
Okay.
Alright, me first.
Go, go, brutal.
Oh, I'm not seeing this.
Nice.
There we go.
I separate.
Middle of the point.
That's where the eat's gonna be.
All right.
Not me.
I somehow got eaten by that.
It's just me.
You guys won't.
I swear.
Oh my god.
You leave.
Jeff's over here.
I'm their teleporter.
They're said teleporter.
They're gonna teleport now.
All right.
I'm ulting this.
When they drop down.
Okay.
Oh, that was very cocky.
Oh, I was gonna actually die.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
Three, two, there you go.
See?
One percent effort.
Goodbye.
Oh, I did not.
There you go.
It's fine.
And see, everything's fine.
See, this is why I just wanted to play Rocket.
it all right there you go all right there we go next game i
swear to god i'm batting gambit i didn't consent to gambit
duty i look at her so at gg why did you give kingsman that
um he was
He was calming already.
I didn't need to calm.
He was doing a great job.
He was doing such a good job.
I didn't need to say anything.
I just need to say meal first.
A good captain does what she's so nice.
I'm just, I'm a good listener.
I calm when I absolutely need to.
all you need to do is capture the mission area it's that
easy all right who won the j3 tournament the community clash
i feel bad for j3 i i didn't he he was very ambitious with
that with that tournament i don't think he realized like to
that skill how how just there you go there you go i just
saved your life that's right Remember me as a hero.
There's someone above us.
Then he's one.
There you go, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
You're so- oh, that spy mask coming!
Sorry, Spirit.
There you go.
Go back up, back up, back up, I'm sorry.
He- she needs to move up more.
There you go.
I'm back here!
Alright, I'll hear.
all right oh we did not need that we did not need that i
didn't realize we were gonna grab two kills there it's like
we're staggering this is a good stagger good stagger you
know look we got boom cleaned this was merely just a stagger
see we've got more time
you stagger he staggered look i didn't realize when i say me
oh i didn't realize that's so all right that's good that's
actually is she alive oh she i was like where am i oh my god
i'm leaving where is that spider-man all right nice see
we're doing it i need to do more damage i'm not doing enough
damage the thing gambit is that you're not supposed to be
heal botting but like also my luna is getting absolutely
fucked up by by the die shit she's getting like hard dope
right now so i feel like i have to i have to like heal her
all right i'm gonna down point hello goodbye Oh, no.
We have Gambit up.
That's the good part.
All right, here we go.
That's all right.
We can go in with Gambit up.
Okay, we have Gambit up.
See?
I'll let Marluna heal now.
I don't need a heal.
All right.
As long as nobody I'm ulting this.
Oh, I did not see that.
oh my god dead core is so low nice all right as long as our
luna doesn't get altered there you go see everything's fine
oh goodbye venom i'm not calling chase you if we die we die
if we die we die
it is oh yeah all right where's the venom venom hey oh my
god he's baiting me he's so smart
that cut he's like you can go and merry go around oh he
touched it
oh hold that guy that's embarrassing
Oh.
Unlucky.
Kill that guy.
Bro, you just got fucked up.
Like, fuck that guy, I guess.
Fuck him.
Alright, now!
Next game I get to play Rocket.
Was he a Gambit one trick?
Oh, he had Lord.
Bro, you cannot be letting me have more damage.
than you, bro.
Bro, I was heal-biting the shit out of my Luna.
Bro, you get it?
You cannot.
That was literally, like, her personal bodyguard.
You cannot have less damage than me.
Who's diving you?
Like, bro, I had Venom and Spiderman and Styler 24-7.
Who the fuck is diving you?
How did you have less damage than me?
I was literally Healbotting!
Anyway, I'm not toxic at all.
There's his inner demons.
Alright.
Alright, go grab some water.
And also use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
But don't worry.
We'll go to the...
We'll have some entertainment.
I'll let you guys watch this duel.
I'll be back I'm
back I haven't been streaming for oh no I'll stop at the
four hour mark technically I have to stream tomorrow as well
I might do the sponsor thing tomorrow as well which was
organized but I will do a rival stream tomorrow because I am
at the show match for the J3 oh shit you know what good wild
Deadpool um but I'm in the commune I'm in the show match for
the j3 tournament um that would be at I think 4 p.m.
EST I think they said it in EST I mean let me check real
quick on the discord uh let me double check real quick uh
all right j3 tournament show match announcement all right I
will be on What?
Aw, I wanted to be, aww Alright, I mean Might as well,
alright, so it is It is on February, oh it's tomorrow, it's
on 2pm PST, sorry I got that, it's 2pm PST Uh, No, but they
said it's tomorrow Tomorrow is The show match day For the
finals, and I'm on team with Flats, Craigie, Day, Malaya,
and Lulu Lovely against Bougar, Moxie, Rain, Kingsman, Choco
Bars, and FanFan.
What the fuck?
They get triple support.
Oh, wait.
We get triple.
Oh, my God.
He's forcing triple support.
What?
J3 is forcing triple support.
I just realized.
This is a fucking triple support cop.
That's fucking hilarious, though, that, like...
Wait, did Mox ever do it with Kingsman?
That's, like, hilarious that Mox and Kingsman are on the
same team.
Yeah, because, like, there's three supports on each team.
Why did you force triple support?
They literally put three supports on each team.
It's not 2-2-2.
Oh, boy.
Yummy yummy triple support Yeah, because it's like wait we
don't even it's one two three we're playing triple support
and we don't even have two ticks Okay for those who don't
know I'm playing rocket not that not that but for those who
don't know Triple support comp is I want rocket I'm fucking
playing fuck you I the tab back in um so so the the meta for
triple support it has to be two one two one three it's two
tanks one dps three uh supports but he literally distributed
the players where there it's uh one tank two dps and three
supports i don't know how this is gonna go 30 seconds before
you attack get ready I want to play cloak because I wanted
little effort right now in this one game yeah for both teams
yeah because Bougar is a tank okay team team one my team
flats tank Craigie Day DPS Malaya Doki Lulu three supports
team two Bougar tank Moxie Moxie Kingsman DPS Rainbow Choco
bars fan fan For both these crazy
Oh my god We can't even not go triple support Oh I don't put
I don't put the I don't put it for any character Because
like I hate some of the characters Thing It's very
distracting sometimes Like especially for Luna I just turn
it out for everyone She has a Luna Disco shit.
I don't know when it's attack or damage.
It's so hard to see.
I think the.
Oh my god.
I thought that.
I didn't think he was going to get knocked up.
Probably here.
Yeah, I think her Disco.
The Luna Disco thing is so distracting.
In general.
Like I cannot tell which one is.
Which one is damage boost and which one is support.
So I just turn.
it out for everybody.
I think a lot of them are super distracting.
I'm fucking leaving.
Sayonara.
Oh my god.
He, they farmed a lot from us.
We do have a moon night.
I am ready to put on a show.
Oh my.
Oh.
Let's hope.
Do it.
I gotta grab this and then I...
Alright, do they have MAGA?
Nope!
We live!
I took a huge gamble, they're hoping that they did not have
MAGA.
Like, I hope they got...
Oh, he flew so fast.
Eh, you're fine, right?
Bro, that Luna is fucking crazy.
Oh, we did not need a used portal.
That was so winnable.
Yeah, I won the Gamba.
I was like, I hope they don't have Mega.
I don't know where to go.
I could have went to that cubby.
That's why J3 slam dunked me like 20 times.
I lost the Gamba every fucking time.
But hey, not last.
Third place.
Was the lowest ranked player in the entire tournament.
place other captains told us that literally okay for those
who weren't who are new viewers literally other captains
were like we're saying my team was the worst team in the
entire tournament hey not last not last though didn't count
knocked out first might be the the lowest ranked That's it,
Kira!
Top three!
They're like, why did Doki pick these people on her team?
She's so stupid!
Still hollering?
Home... I'm leaving now.
Oh my god, he's going to use that and it's not going to be
on me.
Oh,
that's unlucky.
I don't know what to do about that.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
That was a no-reg.
It's not a no rank.
Yeah, and I got knocked up by the champion team.
So technically second if you think about it.
It's technically second place.
All right.
That's fine.
You guys bunch up here and then blinded!
You're blind temporarily.
Jesus Christ, I hope you'll be alive after this.
No, he was not.
Wait, is this actual nectar or a role-play nectar?
We're gonna keep each other alive.
Alright.
Line it!
Oh my god, he was one.
I'm so sad.
No.
Go, go, go!
Oh!
um oh man to be fair i had hope that he would really oh my
gosh okay
landed i'm still in my little orb oh yeah i got raised i
legitimately thought they would live i thought you know i i
could have kept my a little bit, but you know, we are
running one team.
Oh, I should have kept my all that to you.
That's a little silly of me.
Just a little silly of me.
Oh, I need to save it for it.
I have to save it for so many things.
I gotta save it for it.
Can I?
Okay, just in time.
There we go.
I have this.
There's Starlord ult.
There's Groot ult.
There's Magic ult.
There's too many ults.
They have too many combos.
Why did you go back?
You had a little cubby hook.
Oh my god.
You don't have to go back now.
You don't have to go back in now.
You already inserted.
too late.
It's already too late.
Please.
Oh no.
Oh, he's so stupid.
It's so stupid.
Were you all trying to off there, Groot?
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
Oh, Oh my god!
Okay, I'm gonna let my...
Oh, I cannot let him.
Alright, you have to save it for...
Please, you have to...
Please, you have...
Oh, no.
He has to save his rocket ult for Starlord.
If he is smart, he would save it for rocket ult.
If he is smart, he would save it for...
No.
No!
Please, we have... Okay.
That is good.
because, oh, that is not good.
It's...
You can expect too much.
Alright, so they do have Q to win right now.
From...
They...
They do have Q to win, which I am assuming is gonna be very
bad.
Oh,
there it is.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, they're so low.
They're so low, though.
I am.
Wait, they're running.
Oh, wait, no.
They're...
Is this actual next day or...
Or role play next day.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
LARP guy.
Yeah, I don't I don't think If that's real No, the other guy
Swapped a strange to TP He's not, he was in support He was
on support before Fine Wait Uh, okay We can solo support
this That's possible
Alright, let me Oh Oh oh i might be able to tweet something
for the event anniversary tonight after the stream oh wait
yeah 30 seconds before you attack get ready you know what's
worse this is technically a top 500 it's like technically uh
the tier but like a rank below top 500 also sleepy uh spots
thank you for the twitch prime then you think that's the
worst part that's That's the worst part.
Oh,
we swap rolls.
Oh, we're going- No, I don't go- I go- I go- Oh, this then.
We're running close.
We swap rolls.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go!
I mean, they don't technically They don't have anything
against me as Loki.
God damn, I just wanted to play a chill character.
I mean, never usable until they start saying slurs.
Until they start slings first and then maybe...
Ah, nice.
There is a group behind us.
us though see it in us and they start seeing gamer roots
then maybe it's usable I assume we can body block her oh she
she was coming to play oh my god I really didn't think he
was gonna come back all right nice I mean are we really
gonna let our Okay, look, we are.
Okay, I was gonna say, are we really gonna let that happen?
Apparently, yes.
The answer is yes.
The answer is, unfortunately, we are gonna let our cloak
just die.
I guess.
Okay, I want to copy my cloak early so I can use this.
oh my god let's do this all right let's go there we go oh my
god no oh my god he wasted there we go they should oh they
two ults two ults for one two ults all right are cloak
altered oh guys we have a Cloak up now.
Okay, unfortunately.
Oh.
I know.
Unfortunately not really.
Oh my god, I wanted to press F.
I forgot it.
That's unfortunate.
I mean.
That's...
Oh man.
Wasn't my fault.
Alright, here we go.
that's so awkward i i thought she had it i was like don't
worry guys we have clue boat oh there you
oh oh don't worry i can save him well i did not want to use
that but that's okay no lamps now
That's all right.
My life don't matter.
I'm just a support.
What the fuck is he doing?
Eh.
I'll charge.
I'll take that.
What are they doing back there?
Oh, they're dead.
Oh, they got the res.
Is he gonna be okay?
Can't tell.
Oh my god.
The Iron Man.
I haven't seen Iron Man in so long, guys.
Does the lab...
Does the lab save me from Iron Man?
I actually am...
I actually don't remember.
The only reason is that...
Okay, he should live that.
I actually don't know because I haven't seen Iron Man in 20
years.
No, it does.
Okay.
I need a note.
Like, it's actually very important.
Because I don't remember.
I feel like Iron Man has not been meta for 20 season.
Alright, Lamps does not save you from Iron Man.
That's good to know.
That's actually very good to know.
Alright, I type.
You could...
Up first.
So he can bait the Magneto out.
And then I can chill.
Alright.
You're the baiter now.
Not me.
that's very unfortunate i think my emma lives though emma
you gotta see in the lamp buddy you really gotta stay in the
lamp do it come on come on clue thank you that's on you oh
she lives oh they don't they don't have mag anymore oh so
when she gets to oh they don't have a mag that's cool that's
fucking cool oh yeah so when i oh they have mag but when she
ult she's five oh
wait how
It's true!
Okay.
I wanted to- I just- I was like, he's right there.
It's like I caught my- like, like cheap, like the fucking
counterterrorist.
I was thinking about CS and I flew too close to the fucking
sun.
I was like, oh my god, I can stab him.
He's so stabbable.
This giant tree is so stabbable right now.
I'm looking...
That's on me, I'm sorry.
Can you really blame me though?
It was so stabbable.
It was literally right there.
I have many points.
oh my god thank god i got that for my emma driston tab
oh if i didn't have to reload i can heal him oh he really
gotta fucking get that guy
oh oh oh good luck nope nice oh never mind not nice did he
die all right do we have tp because i have oh so someone's
got a tp oh all right all right all right here we go
i just had to chop it
all right here we go i see you i see i see Oh my god, I
really want to stab you right.
I see you too
All right, there you go Please please
Oh we made it Three two three all right Time to how can you
see it?
all right we made it you'll need a top-notch team to win
this one i am loki go ahead and the queen rage swapping the
iron mat well i don't even know which one is him bro we have
a guy with 16 kills guys like bro are you looking at tab
yeah i was gonna say bro we got we have some guy with seen
kills and i figure iman is doing fine our guy our guy is i
told you every game is always someone's problem i have no
idea what they're even arguing about anymore
1v9 on moon night
My god.
I just want to be a silly rat.
I didn't want to fucking play.
Loki.
I just want to be a silly rat.
The amount of brain power.
Instead of hee hee.
Hee.
I had a cooking of... be aware of my goddamn...
Oh my god.
I'm going to use my lamp here.
I didn't know if people would be...
He's back!
Oh my god!
Why did no one turn around?
No one actually turned around.
That's crazy.
It was just me and Cloak.
Defending for ourselves.
How the fuck did no one turn around for us?
That's crazy
He literally came we literally just needed one DPS to turn
around and just shoot him because I have to spend my time
shooting Shooting my support.
Oh no, she used her bubble He's gonna jump one of us.
I don't know who.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he turned around.
Oh my god!
He turned around!
See, that's all I need to do!
He actually turned.
He needed one DPS to turn around.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're on.
Yeah, oh, now he turns around when we lost the boy.
So they can feel it was just a choice.
It was just a choice not to.
I tried to give the benefit of doubt, maybe, you know,
because no one's talking that no one knew.
But it was just a choice.
They just decided not to.
They're like, fuck that.
If you wish.
What society can exist without lies?
Here we go.
Alright.
I will be honest with you guys.
I don't know if this is winnable.
I believe this might be difficult because the venom
literally got two picks right off the bat on support I gotta
be real guys this does not look winnable
like the fact that their Iron Man has a bigger influence
fact is my moon night when moon night is like a lot more
meta right now
that's crazy for those who don't know moon night is
technically like more meta right now
all right all right we did it we got
oh my god i need to reload oh my god there you go Oh my god.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad for me.
We don't have ults.
It's like they have two tanks or something.
The farm ults on.
It's actually crazy.
It's like they have two tanks!
The farm ults off!
Oh my god.
You're like, it's like, I might not have your IP.
Yeah, no, it's because they have two teams.
The power of an ult battery.
Yo, 40.
Yo, but 45k damage on...
Yes, I wonder how their supports got so many support alts.
I wonder how...
Man!
Man, I wonder how did their support ult build so fast
compared to us.
That's so crazy.
Yeah, it truly is a mystery.
I'm a Moon Knight that did 45 King damage.
That's alright, I'm here.
Oh my god!
That's a big ass door!
Oh my god, that Thor is huge.
Wait, where is it?
Alright, hello Thor, would you like the holy ravioli?
Wait, what rank is he?
What rank is this guy?
Oh my god, the chef was like, no.
No, I got kicked by the bouncer!
No!
The bouncer kicked me out.
Oh shit, he's on the, he's on the chair now.
It's perfect.
Wait, I have to be like, I have to look this way.
No, I have to look this way.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I was your first buddy.
There we go.
I got...
area.
If only the other oh, I can watch this 1v1 duel as well
while we're doing this.
I can watch this sick ass 1v1 between that guy and the other
guy.
Throwing it back with my liege.
Alright, this is LG, guys.
Guys, LG.
Oh my god, forgot to avoid the guy.
Give me a sec.
If I get him on my team, I deserve it.
I deserve it.
He's on my team.
All right, now I have to play Rocket.
I'm going to get Water, too.
Oh, they do the bad phase.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
I am back.
They bent.
Please never go to a casino.
We did it even, Basilow!
We didn't even ask Loki.
Well, that's the big I'm already.
play low-key
Alright I literally just played low-key Oh my god We need a
second tank I swear to god if our moonlight was the guy I
did not avoid I swear to god Mantis do you play tank I swear
to god
I'm so weird.
Or DPS?
There ain't no trick.
Oh my god.
I just wanted to play the fucking rat.
I want her to chill.
I really did.
Guys, I have some bad news.
Hi, ran out of cough drops today.
I mean, we have three supports.
Alright, one of them, two of them down!
Wait!
Oh my god, oh my god, they're fucking running, Jeff.
A fucking course.
Oh my god.
They're running.
Oh my god, they have the better gambo.
big combo unfortunately their their comp on paper is a
better only because they have two tanks um they have two
tanks and they do have okay i did say on paper but like i
don't know it doesn't count for skill i guess It's because
they have Starlord and Starlord Gambit is so strong in
general.
It's very, very OP.
Man, if only we had a rocket to get that Riz off.
I leave.
Just in case.
I had...
I had All right Come on, come on How do you still not have?
Oh my god
I stopped healing I I even stopped i don't know if you guys
saw that i was like there's no way here i'm gonna not heal
i'm gonna i'm gonna not heal real quick that's cool okay i i
do that just like there you go oh my god like i was like we
all we all saw me stop healing right we all saw that
mean you don't have it yet i'm not even healing no more all
right i have shift now i was a little worried about that oh
god oh my god he's still dead i'm just gonna hello everybody
I'm set, don't use anyone.
Alright, oh shit, nice.
Let's hope he doesn't die.
Oh, okay.
Maybe a little too early.
For sure.
I'm behind you.
Alright.
Goodbye.
I don't, I...
I legitimately...
You could tell that I...
I know that that rock was for me.
Like, guys, I knew instantly.
I was like, I'm not fucking...
Oh, I did not mean to do that.
I'd fucking...
I live.
I don't know how.
Never punished.
Never fucking punished, I guess.
Whoops.
That's why I don't push aggressively anymore.
All right, let's go.
Oh.
Okay.
Like, chill, guys.
Come on, Maddie.
I don't know how the fuck I killed Maddie.
All right, Spotted.
You do your job.
I think they got the portal, guys.
Guys, I'm very scared.
I'm very scared, guys.
I think we need a portal, guys.
That sounds like real, but I think.
I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
Please kill me.
I'm going to...
I want a portal, but you guys can be touched.
I tried.
Someone is better.
I just started Portal.
It's like a 2-1-3.
Like I said, guys.
On paper.
Their comp is a lot better than my comp.
Also, Chamber.
Thank you for the tier one.
So thank you.
Thank you.
I feel like we need two tanks.
We don't have damage.
We don't do anything with just Spuddy.
Coffee.
The Spider-Man has a better KDA.
Look at.
Coffee!
Coffee, the Spider-Man is doing more.
You already, it's already over.
Oh no, the reason why we, it's because we lost the alt
rotation because our gamut didn't build alt in time.
I even like stopped healing to be like, you got this, you
got this buddy.
I'm not left clicking.
I feel like we just need to get our own.
look at me i'm not i'm not doing it
the fact that like
if only they banned loki and fucking all right waiting
go go Oh Is this a one time I
There you go There you go Period the one time I actually can
be aggressive because I they had nothing They're going to
get there soon.
I'm going to let the I'm going to let them I'm gonna let
them heal I'm gonna let my gambit.
I can try getting that.
I'm gonna let them heal.
See I am I'm just gonna I'm just gonna look at the DPS.
Let me DPS Yeah, I'm gonna mag this Star Lord only trying to
see I'm just trying to DPS right here I'm not I'm not
healing All right, there you go.
We have Mantis already so I can heal again But fuck this guy
How did our Spider-Man die?
Like, oh my god.
Gavin never falls!
It truly never falls!
Oh my god!
Did someone say Gavin never falls?
Oh my god.
Holy fuck, I guess I did.
Oh.
We lost the alt rotation in the end.
We really did.
Oh, I hate this meta.
And the J3 gave us one, two, and three!
He put three supports on both teams!
We're in a show match!
Oh my god, it's literally whichever team rotates first.
Alright.
Yeah, but truly it never falls.
Alright I will have...
There we go.
Please can we kill the mag?
He's chilling.
All right, I'm gonna let my Gambit heal, and then I'm just
gonna DPS here.
All right, I'm gonna put my nestle over here.
All right, Gambit heal.
I'm just gonna be DPSing.
I'm heal Gambit.
I'm not, I'm not gonna do anything else.
Sorry, behind.
This guy dies.
Nice.
There we go.
Okay, I, this sucks.
I didn't do anything.
Oh my god, did I get it?
Oh my god, I got it.
This is it.
Oh my god, I have to get this.
There you go.
I couldn't find my gambit.
This was the closest.
This was the...
This is the closest.
I was like...
I was like, I can't find...
Fuck it.
This is the best.
I can do.
We have Gambit at home.
I am accused of loving chaos.
He just tried.
All right.
Let's see who has a better support alt rotation because this
is going to be a little rough.
I accept this minor improvement.
All right.
Let's try this out.
All right, here we go.
because I I don't know if I should have meant to I got a
little scared.
I got a little scared there.
I hope I hope that meant to that copy was not a throw.
Three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Alright.
Because I did not know if we were gonna win that.
I was very It might have a Gambit, so we just farm for
Mantis here.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna DPS then.
Ah, he went Namur.
Okay, just stay there.
Who the fuck was he?
Alright.
Nice, we waited to ensure that...
Oh, Gambit never fell soon!
And we don't have any ult.
Unless we get time to build all.
Okay, we still have time.
We still have time.
We have time to build all.
That's good.
Alright.
We still have time to build it.
They most likely will have Gambit ult.
So I am a little worried.
I'm going to try and let my other Gambit build it.
no oh no come on
not me oh maybe oh no maybe me oh my god this is it get it
get it get it get it get it get it get it yes Oh my god.
Oh,
that is awkward.
Oh, please.
Hello.
Hi.
All right.
Hey guys, there is like people There are people here There
we go Okay, our mantis is fucking crazy Our mantis might be
the fucking gamer right now Oh my god Our mantis is actually
a gamer Okay Now My mantis don't know Okay, um, we don't
really have alt.
So, let's just hope.
What the fuck?
Guys, I don't think that works.
I think that definitely does not work, guys.
I don't think that works.
They more know, Bubba.
Do you think they know?
You think they know?
there's no way oh that's oh my god yeah no
i thought we're gonna let them have it oh maybe winnable i'm
almost there oh okay well um i don't have lambs now yeah we
portal here maybe we win portal i don't know can we portal
we're at 23 bro we can just we can just double gambit all
right we can just come back to her all right we can go far
left you guys after that hello that scared me i inked i
inked there that scared me i got hit one time and i was like
clone i might distract from my side for you i'm not over in
here all right three
That's fucking right!
Boom!
Oh, I'm okay.
Man, this is that.
Wait, where is my gambit?
Come on, gambit.
Wait, where?
Give me my gambit.
Where is my gambit?
Where is my...
Gambit, please!
Where are you?
Give me that point.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Well, I didn't think we were gonna win that, but...
Alright.
Um...
Wait, wait, go stop it!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
oh my god i did it i was like okay that mantis sort of like
ulted me i was like not today oh my god i was like check
your id yo now our mantis was fucking crazy like our mantis
actually single-handedly carry this entire game.
Our gambit, I will say.
Mantis and me build so much faster than our Mantis.
This Mantis was crazy.
If he was acting, I will not be surprised.
like, he was very, his aim was crazy.
His aim was so good.
He was, he's like, bro, he has the same titles as her
fucking spider-man yeah that mantis aim was insane yeah she
built alt faster than me it was like her and me and then
gamut all right that was a good game to end on the secret
yeah he was she was our second dps yeah they were like no
it's cool i want to be a mantis now he turn on the secret
weapon right there all right guys i'm gonna call it here
today uh thank you all for watching uh thank you shout out
again to kingsman for the raid i was very surprised that he
knew of me and that he wanted a duo like i think like i've
never bumped into him in rank before other than today i
think just i usually play because he's like a college kid
right so he plays you know he he usually plays i usually
play in degenerate hours as in like i usually play at where
I pop up like at like 11 p.m.
and over um but today I was just like I want to I'm mad I
want to games were yeah games were pretty rough earlier
today so I was like I'm gonna stream because I'm mad uh yeah
and he plays on normal human hours so this is like the first
time I've ever bumped into Kingsman uh during rank hours so
um yeah GG's uh thank you everybody who came from the
Today's stream, if you're a new viewer here, I usually
stream on YouTube, so please check me out on YouTube.
And give me a subscribe, because I'm trying to hit a million
subscribers this year.
Anyone know whenever I stream on Twitch, please check me out
on Twitter.
I usually tweet out whenever I stream on Twitch, because
Twitch is where I do the spontaneous streams, or if I have a
sponsor here or anything, is where I stream here.
I have my merch store is down today this week because we're
going in some renovations on our merch store It'll be up
next week, but you're supporting me.
There are other stuff you can support me by with using my
code on Fortnite Fortnite gamer subs or EA.
I do have a dokeybird code for all three of those places Why
do I not stream on both?
Because I do not have two PCs.
I do not do dual stream.
I not do dual streaming for because I would get 50 frames
only because I don't have dual PCs.
I stream all of this on one PC and, you know, 100 frames is
doable, but 50 is not.
Last time we tried to do dual streaming with Rivalis, it was
like chugging along at 30 to 50 frames.
And I have a 5090, by the way.
I bought 5090 in a RAM before the surge pricing, before AI
became a big thing.
and I have a lot of and I have a 50-90 and I still get 30 to
50 frames if I do dual streaming of rivals.
Yeah, so that is why I just choose one platform.
Um, hey guys, thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys time everybody well yes wow thank you all
for the follows the bitties the donations thank you guys and
the souls bye bye everyone bye